[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yo
crown
sunday
the lord's day what's going on
how my levels are sounding
lord metroid what's up cheryl mack or
hell the ilp salute i already know corey
mosley what's going on man warlord thank
you brother follow super chat shout out
to the guys in them
notification gang early that's what's up
everybody got the notification hustle
what's up all my levels are sounding bro
dallas what's up six slayer what's up
tell 108 to get that stop um fear
mongering oled tvs
[ __ ] get your boy he wild right now we
gotta put him through therapy
hustle what's up man no no no lies
what's going on so you already know what
it is attic talk to the people right
quick
what's going on guys i'm here i'm here
today he's here lucious augustus that's
my guy man salute appreciate your
question on defining duke that's what's
up yeah sick runaway is wilding man he
he got like oled trauma
it's gonna burn in it's gonna burn it
i'm gonna use it for movies
what are you my homie so i can clown you
anyway know it in center what's
he said it was fine see that's where i
got a call i got to put the pride alert
on our old oh
if you got to watch something twice
he said he appreciated on the second one
so that's where he was
he had that thought process like can i
really have this because if you guys
think something you got to watch
something twice part of me feels like
you was you was questioning you know he
said he was he actually admitted he said
he was a little questioning
or whatever but anyway did i do the tv
update i did not do the tv update on my
cx yet i'm just gonna wait for the for
the rollout the natural rollout is
october for all cx users that's gonna
allow the 4k 120 dolby vision gaming so
i'll be patient i know everybody's doing
a korean update with the firmware my
luck i feel like i'll do it i'll break
something
[Music]
but look enough of that y'all know what
it is we got the legend in the building
he's gonna be here seth
you already know the legend xbox
communication
everything man huge huge day for us king
will be pulling up
and um saul should be here as well we
got the full attic everybody's here it's
gonna be a good one man such chazelle
the legend
you know what i mean it's gonna be it's
gonna be a big one so we will be back
we'll get him in the room king will be
coming through with music so we're gonna
mute and when dallas will check y'all
let's go get these dallas balls right
quick
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the snapple and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on a b.o dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them range
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
about coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my
vocals but i'm anti-social love my city
but i'm still by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is yoga fire flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when he was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
and turn me to an animal and headless be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
love my city but i'm still by coastal i
got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
is
[Music]
imma just chill and watch them many
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine this cooler give
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you gonna get tossed
in the bushes by king david royalty and
not a pretender detrimental to an
elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto i know it's my
destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swearing away something but really be
stevo
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it and nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on
[Music]
all right
hot mike's here
hear ye hear you and we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 229 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm extremely
excited about our special guest and
we've got xbox communication
a vow details leak dc fandom 2021 and
the latest nintendo news to discuss so
we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
tremendous passion for the games
industry and illustrious career within
the world of journalism has truly
ascended him into the business of
interactive entertainment and now ready
to power our dreams within a new
generation of xbox
introducing the director of executive
communications for team xbox and the
former iconic journalist of the new york
times plus co-founder of fans.live
the lord of critical thinking and gaming
friendships
who's been known
to go on a war tour with muhammad my man
playing forza horizon 4 with the drink
in his head
live from washington and making his
debut into the realm of the lords
my man lord seth chazelle how we doing
sir
it's so awesome to be here
you know thank you so much for having me
really appreciate it it's really great
you know as we uh if we bring the joy in
community of gaming to everyone on the
planet it's just awesome to have the
opportunity to introduce myself a little
bit to the community yes big fan of the
show
and uh just thanks for having me thank
you dave you know what i do want to
bring something up oh lord you know
every time he does an intro for another
individual i get a little bit more salty
but he just did yours man man king like
come on man strike let's do it like i
already told you anytime you're ready to
do a stage walk out walk out
the adjustment of the extra sauce
look man you are lord in your room
absolutely honored we had to show you
the proper respect here in the room
what's been going on man how you what
games have you been playing
yeah so you know i thought i'd just walk
you through uh like a typical saturday
for me so like yesterday so you know we
had a little pre-call in the morning
okay
and i went back to my apartment
and the first thing i did is uh i fired
up my six accounts and eve online oh
he plays the games i'm scared of okay
but yeah if you will back away a little
bit you tell him you're an eve player
you know
you know what i say sometimes is you
know eve players are to nerds what nerds
are to normal people yes
yes yes yes
respect you know as i do i have to check
in just make sure everything's going all
right uh with that and checking on
discord with my people yes yes uh so
that took a little while um then i
popped over to uh final fantasy 14.
i've just oh so he plays all the games
i'm scared of okay i just started uh
that a few months ago so having some fun
with that i did some of the daily
activities and whatnot uh in final
fantasy nice um and then i jumped into
far cry 6. okay okay cool uh i hadn't i
hadn't started that yet and uh i've got
a pretty decent pc and just the graphics
on that are incredible and i'm actually
really into the storytelling i'm a big
fan of the far cry franchise so spend
some time with that uh and then just to
wrap up at night um back into a strategy
game that i play a lot of called europa
universalis four which is from paradox
interactive sort of a historical
strategy game i'm playing as hawaii and
i'm trying to take over the world as
hawaii nice nice
and let's get it
get out who would dance on everybody
that's like
when it comes to like i really want to
jump in final fantasy 14 and i even
jumped in that game
and i left because i was scared
like i i have an addictive personality
but i never feed it like i tried my
heart is not defeated i i fed mine to a
world of warcraft yeah so when it comes
to see see that's what it is like i
don't want to stop playing everything
before team
i already had the issue of destiny i and
i'm i'm finally able to like serve
destiny the divorce papers
i'm okay with where i am right now but
if i pick up that fortune you know what
it is yeah you could only be here with
those type
all right trust me i i know this
struggle i know this show that's very
cool man i definitely like that's a lot
of games lineup of games so we're gonna
have way more to talk about but we gonna
get into it and you already know we got
the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with those updated king
five minute king
time sensitive
king updated
[Laughter]
i'll teach you the ways of the force
thank you thank you that goes with the
combos my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man you know uh thank
everyone for coming through i apologize
for missing last week but i brought it
around
i am i'm uh i i'm i'm like at like 70 i
can't say i'm at a hundred but i'm like
70 percent
uh but you know appreciate except for
coming on man because because it's it's
mad early over there on the west coast
man
everyone in the chat that is watching
this on the west coast i've been in need
of you because i can't not me not me
you ain't about
[Laughter]
respect good to see you man i know
you've been going through it a lot of
pain trust me i've had the wisdom teeth
out that is not easy so respect you you
know what i'm saying but um and of
course we have our most technical gaming
lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patriarch
of the iron bank my man lord sanford how
are we doing sir i'm doing well i'm glad
to be back
here with you guys and seth uh my
apologies for missing last week it kind
of could not be helped uh
i went out saturday night uh you know we
were all supposed to go out and i wound
up just going out with uh lord marlonius
and we just we we saw a venom and then i
got i got home and i just i was ready to
just hang out with with lady saab got a
call from my sister and next thing i
know i'm not home until sunday
late afternoon minute you know so
sometimes family stuff comes up so my
apologies no no question life comes
first brother you know that yeah yeah of
course um and
quickly i wanted to shout out two lords
who are donated to our gofundme for for
lord sinister and his family but donated
directly to us so then we passed it
along so i just want to make sure that i
give them a shout out so but first off
we give a shout out to gamingtime's pat
for your donation thank you so much
thank you so much appreciate it then we
have lord anthony vasquez aka ghost b18
thank you as well for your donation we
really appreciate it um and sinister's
family really appreciates it so so thank
you so much
so real quickly what i have been playing
so uh
it's been a whole lot of metroid dread
and a whole lot of switch oled if you
play
portably
that it's a good
thing if you're not don't buy that it's
basically massive
deficiencies of resolution
okay got it
i actually put on far cry 6 a little bit
yesterday i played for about two hours
okay um it's far baylor was trying to
get me to play that game he was like
david why don't you get it and i'm like
no we're dead yeah you missed the game
it's far cry it's far cry and if you
like far cry you're really going to
enjoy it uh the story stuff i'm kind of
over like sometimes people animals are
meaning
oh you start off with the croc
and i and i stayed with the croc
i want the chihuahua the chihuahua if
you want to play stealthily that's your
that's where you want to go um so let me
get these super chats really quick no no
no doubt what we got oh and i watched
halloween kills and no yeah no no
[Laughter]
so first off we got warlord 10 15. five
dollars a chat shout out to the guys in
them notification gang here early
much love
then we have lucius augustus five
dollars to be checked if you spent
seventy dollars on godfall at launch you
have no right to question if metroid
dread is worth 60 dollars
how did this conversation happen yeah
with the five dollar super chat i just
want to say that all the death threats
to the blue box game studio have
received as unacceptable and disgusting
my support is for them today
uh wow death threats really yeah that's
kind of crazy that's crazy
um
ten dollar super chat proud of you lord
it's always glad to see people getting
their shine here tell your loved ones
you love them and smell some roses
absolutely
sir did that all yesterday
and
we have anything are we caught up with
every lesson we choose the last one yes
okay cool let's go and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka the
access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
better than mikey garcia
oh it was that oh man so let me let me
tell you something this is what happens
when keeping it real goes wrong he went
and he want to pick uh uh mr martinez
and uh mr martinez sorry mr martine it
was a heavy underdog and he believed in
himself and he told everybody before the
fight pick me
bet on me
the guy believed it he walked the walk
mikey garcia did believe that he could
walk the walk and talk to talk and uh
that l goes to you sir have a good day
yes
it was a fantastic thing to see because
what i want everyone to understand is
when you fight just fight the best don't
waste your time doing anything else if
you're at the upper tail level keep
fighting the best so now mikey has to
fight
and i'm going to have a great time
because he has to fight real hard fights
but okay so what i was playing this week
i forgot all about my games with gold
so i ran into my games with gold i'm
like oh what's in there so is this um
game called aerial um it's a music beat
game okay it's pretty good it's um
it reminds me of selfie when you're
going forward
yeah
music is really good it's really nice
but that hover
i went over to this other game called
hover okay and
that game actually was insane because it
remind me of jet set radio wow
the level of uh customization that you
had with your character was insane um
game pass dropped a couple of games that
i was truly interested in
um i was watching attic uh play
uh this um that strategy game oh so i
had exploited yeah phoenix yeah so i
watched he was playing he was he was
hardcore into it and i was like i was
like okay that's pretty cool but um they
dropped this uh back for blood oh yeah
all right you left for dead fans day one
game pass there's absolutely zero excuse
for you to
to to not try this game yes
it is the most organic game i mean the
game feels alive uh with the the the
the level of interaction with the vocals
like stuff that you do yeah it's
actually it's happening in real time i'm
still trying to figure out how the hell
did these devs do this how did those
but but the language it's like little
things that you know
the bad stuff somebody else is doing and
i'm like it's so spot on this is is in
it's uncanny right okay so um that you
have a card system
and this card system makes the game
fresh every time you play and how you
play
uh you like you could be a healer you
could be a tank
everyone you can have the same character
but it's not going to be the same
loadout it's not going to be the same
experience especially if you're playing
with multiple different people at
different periods of time the way the
board is set up is not like procedurally
generated it's it's the same board but
the way to have the placement of the
impact of the characters
it's insane it's the most organic game
that i've no two experiences are the
same with the way the enemy placement
stuff like that yeah it's real fun i've
noticed
make that game a lot different too yes
yes agree i was seeing uh i was hanging
out with acg on discord and i was seeing
like cards were making like the whole
party different like yes yeah it's dope
because i was um i was type i'm the type
of dude i don't want to take any
negative cards right so all the cards is
positive cause it helps the team so if i
get a power up my team gets a power warp
and we were doing achievements where
nobody like got dropped or nobody was
falling while we're doing the game so we
got some diamond achievements out of
that but that is i've waited for this
game for a while so when they did show
it this is the first game that i can
honestly say this year lived up exactly
to the expectations and i have really
high expectations for turtle rock on
this game yeah and they actually
exceeded those expectations a lot of
games met my expectations right this
game far exceeded that and of course
destiny you know of course of course no
doubt no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself this [ __ ] no beat
lord cognito spreading that realness in
the realm of iop not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to the latest defining duke
with myself maddie plays and the amazing
legend ryan mccaffrey you guys stopped
by a lot of fun check that out that
should go up off 3.99 in about an hour
or so so if you want to check that out
on last stand media and then also we did
uh define and do ultimate where we kind
of just broke down some top requested
games from xbox back compat a lot of fun
so check that out and then uh last word
you bought this tie guy travis salute
hoglaw pulled up hulk love hold up we
got the legality of the destiny content
vault he had his words he wanted to say
a lot of fun there and um check that out
and of course as far as games back for
blood like king was saying phoenix
protocol like attic was saying um
and then i've been doing on
that game yeah okay i was gonna say that
phoenix point is like broke me man like
yes
i've had to restart that game so many
times it's unreal yeah it's tough and uh
for vr king um i highly recommend it's
an older game remember i'm new to vr so
i'm playing catch up on oculus quest 2.
it's called traveling while black very
well you heard about that
very impactful
and it just shows you the ways vr could
be used to really teach stories and it's
it's powerful man very emotional you got
to check that out i was i heard that the
the level of interactivity and the
barriers that it's breaking down yeah is
is it's i think they should be teaching
it in school yeah like literally i felt
like i would retain more if i was a kid
in this generation
yeah you know learning it that way
because it felt like i'm in this
interactive museum while things are
going on around me in the time period it
happened so it was very very powerful
very powerful i highly recommend it so
solve this real quick let's set up the
rules of engagement because we got to
get to our guests
yeah so you guys as you know when we
have a guest that has limited time we
want to respect that as much as possible
so all super chats that come in
obviously will be read uh towards the
end of the show afterwards um but we got
to respect such time because
if you can see behind him it's still
dark
over on the west coast where he is so um
yeah so thank you so much for all for
all your questions and comments we will
definitely address those afterwards yeah
actually there was you want to get the
just those last three that just came in
and then we'd be done because it wasn't
before give me a while man i think i
could take care of you i think it was um
it was just i just see hearts
yeah you got it's my easy already and
and tazza oh i got uh yeah i got all
that all right cool
yeah just hard yeah we should be good
chaney five dollars super chat the full
crew in the house and xbox salute to the
lord absolute salute so you already know
so now that we've gotten into what the
lords have been playing we got to focus
on lord seth his video game system
history his lustrous career and as a
journalist over 16 years at the new york
times his work at protocol and of course
what led him to becoming the director of
executive communications at xbox so lord
said let's start from the very beginning
what was some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming
well first of all uh just thanks again
for having me um it's really just an
incredible opportunity um and you know
as we were chatting just the opportunity
to go down sort of memory lane just on a
personal basis here
uh a little bit uh because you know
everyone has their own journey yes and
you know they rarely are smooth
uh they're often uh bumps in the road
uh and you know just thinking about my
whole life uh in games um you know sort
of leading to this opportunity that i
have now it's just really incredible
um and it will start at the beginning
but you know two two years ago uh i was
i was unemployed
i i had been out of work for the better
part of three years
um and i wasn't really sure what the
next step was going to be and so to be
you know in this position now it's just
really incredible that's awesome and you
know putting it sort of in the context
of you know whole life of experiences so
yeah i guess you know i was born in new
york city uh in manhattan um
roosevelt hospital right behind lincoln
center okay okay okay
my parents were in very graduate student
housing at columbia coming down the west
side highway uh to get to the hospital
in time you know
and uh so yeah that was in the early 70s
um and you know as we all know in the in
the late 70s you know it was a tough
time for new york city
um and so a lot of folks were trying to
move out um
my parents had gotten divorced when i
was young and my mom remarried and they
were thinking about moving out of the
city and they wanted to move somewhere
that was close to a big city um not in
the city but close to a big city
and that would be open to this you know
racially mixed family yes um and so we
ended up moving to woodstock new york
what's that about 100 miles north of the
city uh which is a small town
and the the town
uh you know in the woods was basically
split at that time between what i would
call sort of hippie
like my family you know musicians
artists stuff like that but the other
half of the town were ibm families
because ibm the company you know is from
the hudson valley based in armonk and
all those cities up and down the hudson
valley uh kingston peak skill fish kill
poughkeepsie yeah we're all ibm towns
and so in woodstock we had this this mix
between the the very sort of
straight-laced ibm families and then
sort of the the whacked-out hippies yeah
but you to think about it woodstock
right
yeah yeah that's it right but we don't
think of it as like you know these these
straight lace you know middle american
families right because back then being a
computer engineer working for ibm meant
that you put on a three-piece suit and
you drove to the computer yes in the
morning yes right it wasn't about the pc
it was about you know refrigerator-sized
mainframes yep um and but it plays out
and sort of what happened with my gaming
history because
so my mom uh being part of the hippie
intelligentsia would not allow a
television in the house at all
no no tv not even the big back with the
furniture no no no fur no tv of any kind
and even if we had a tv to actually get
an over-the-air signal you would have
needed one of those big aerials on the
roof right like
so but she was like tv will melt your
brain yeah uh
he was calling it the idiot box right
that's what she called it
[Music]
and so she didn't allow that so there's
a lot of music in the house a lot of
books but she let me have a computer
okay okay uh and this goes back to the
sort of the mix in the town so there
were two elementary schools in the town
there was like the public school where
the teachers wear suits and the kids
would call them by mr and mrs and that's
where all the ibm kids went correct um
and because it was an ibm town
they only had a few like ibm computers
right um but you know in the early 80s
you know you know much loved ibm pc um
and dos which was actually obviously
made by microsoft yes
um at that time they had made a deal
with microsoft allowing us to you know
license that to other computer
manufacturers but you know those weren't
the easiest for children to use
obviously at that time this is this is
even before five and a quarter inch oh
wow wow this is eight inch floppies
right before you get down to five and a
quarter in trend but so it wasn't really
part of the education there but at the
hippie school right the other school it
was there
there was the hippie school that i went
to it was a hundred kids in one like
victorian house
um but there and the teachers were
overalls and we would call them by their
first name
and
that is so much it sounds so much fun
right because you see the dichotomy you
see
these cl these kids are laid back rt
kids and you see these straight lace
kids mr misses you know what was it
okay okay from how i'm saying it was
there any teasing going on from both
sides uh you know no the teasing was one
direction right it was fro it was from
the hippie kids towards the straight
lace kids
um but at our hippie school uh we had a
bunch of uh commodore computers
um this was the commodore uh and apple
generation we started off with dick 20s
and then commodore 64s
and those were quite easy for children
to use yes uh because you pop them open
and you have this basic prompt so my mom
no t he had no tv in the house but she
let me have a computer nice uh so i
started off with the commodore and each
town back then was either a commodore
town or an apple town okay and we were a
commodore town and so i got a commodore
vic-20 uh when i was in like whatever it
was like fourth grade the tape drive
right the sword yeah
the tape drive
um and then got commodore 64.
and the games though because the storage
was so limited
you basically we would buy we'd get
magazines right like paper magazines
there's a magazine called compute and
there was compute's gazette
and i think compute was the apple one
and gazette was the commodore one and in
the back of the magazine they would
literally have the code for the games
you'd have to type in the game yes oh
yes
like from
actually the language from the back of
the computer in order to run them and of
course if you didn't type it in right
then it wouldn't run yep um so you're
basically teaching programming as you're
you know giving people the games they
could play
um
and then you know and then of course you
know we get the commercial software the
commodore 64. deep on the original ea
games archon mule seven cities the gold
um but so that was sort of you know me
and i was an only child right so you've
got this only child
in the woods
no tv no no tv
sounds like a horror story
you got this little kid in the woods by
themselves in the basement
uh you know what this just gets worse
you know my big on the commodore you
know at that time in elementary school
you know the big thing for me i was into
you know fantasy role playing and you
know i would get the dungeons and
dragons books and i wanted to play dnd
yes i had no one to play with
uh so i would just go through these dnd
books to start making up my own
adventures but on the computer side
um the big leap forward for me was the
bard's tale series
yeah and one of my favorite childhood
memories was literally seeing the ups
truck come into the driveway and running
out to get the the box
uh to come back in and back then you
know with the graph paper because you
had to graph out the dungeons
you know step by step um so that was
sort of part of the gaming uh for me to
begin with gotcha but the other side is
the social side right and yeah we all
know the most important thing about
gaming is bringing people together yeah
and that and that community it's not
just about you and the games but the
other people and i got that at the
arcade let's go
all right so i didn't have the console
but i had i had the arcade experience
and so in woodstock there was a place
called the pinball palace okay all right
and the pinball palace so all right so
you had the remember the the
straight-laced kids named hippie kids
right yeah and the elementary school
kids on my block they had to get on the
bus and go straight home after
elementary school my mom let me ride a
bike and say all right you know you can
like hang out in town for a little bit
you know before you come back you know
after school but you better not go to
the pinball palace
so of course we went of course
of
the screens emanating what was going on
give me the visual so all right so half
of it you've seen the movie days and
confused you know the place the emporium
with the high school kids hanging out um
but it was smaller than that it was kind
of like this dark little place but uh
right in the middle of town and we
weren't supposed to go there and it was
like the high school kids were there you
know hanging out there's a big
difference between an eight-year-old a
nine-year-old and a 16 year old true
true true but the other side of it was
you know woodstock's a big music town
okay and there was a really famous rock
and roll club in the middle of town
called the joyous lake okay and it was
not a coincidence that the pinball
palace was right behind the joyous lake
okay
and the joyous lake where's where all
these rock and roll and hippie bands
would be coming through you know through
town on tour you know with their roadies
and stuff right right and you know
woodstock has a certain reputation yeah
so they'd come you know play a show but
they were also you know picking up other
things
hey guys
other things
picked up but we're going to continue
they're picking up
the pinball palace was right behind the
joyous lake
and so you know when you're like a rock
band on tour you're loading in in the
late afternoon right yeah before the
show that night the late afternoon is
also when the kids are coming out of
school to go to the pinball palace and
the high school people so you'd have the
rock and roll roadies right you know
hanging out at the pinball palace with
the high school kids but that's where i
got you know my centipede and my pac-man
my my galaga uh
defender
do you remember the first um actual
video game uh stand-up that was there
because all right so what i know what
you're saying is like in in in that
period of time the early 80s
there was a ton of pinball machines and
the pinball machines ruled and then all
of a sudden a stand-up
was there
yeah so my stand-up the first stand-up
that i ever had was um time pilot oh i
know tom pilot yeah yeah so when i
remember going to to see it and i'm like
what was this
and it was a repetitive uh uh shooter
you know a plane shooter
but that was the first stand-up that i
actually seen up close besides a pinball
machine do you remember the first
stand-up or when you got there with
stand-ups already no no let me come back
to that's a really great question king
because the other thing so my stepfather
he owned two laundromats
um and so at night he'd be fixing
washing machines in the garage but we
had pinball machines in the laundromats
so i was a huge pinball guy
you know fina you know fanatic and there
was pinball mostly at the pinball palace
right
and looking what started with space
invaders that's oh class
i mean legit old school space invaders
um i don't remember time pilot but
pretty quickly when i can remember we
were into the sprite era with uh
original pac-man you know i remember
when miss pac-man came out
that changed the game
pac-man was the real step up there right
yeah um but you know it was a tempest
you know yeah
and what's funny is the uh you know we
had tempest with the spinnerball with
the spinner wheel yep um and then galaga
and so the one game that i was always
best at was a game called gyrus
of course gyrus was sort of galaga meets
tempest right yeah with the sprite
graphics around the outside and
what was cool they would leave the
machines on to try to you know because
the height that high score was it right
you come in after school it's like you
know how's my high score doing let's go
and once in a while the power would go
out and reset it yeah but i did become
the number one gyrus player in that town
nice
that was that was my jam but you know it
was the and you know my mom would be
like i think he went to the pinball pack
so that's where go through the gauntlet
of uh shady characters to get to the
action
were they engaging in said activities at
the pinball palace so maybe you came
home
smelling them
you know the 16 year olds were smoking
cigarettes everywhere yeah anything else
would you know be on the back porch they
tell the kids you know you don't want to
go out that way go out the front door
yes yeah uh you know and what not um
try to be somewhat respectful of the
kids so but that social experience right
of like playing in public right yes and
we've largely lost that even now
absolutely um you know with the rise of
home consoles tell them about the
pressure of playing a pinball machine
and you got that high score rocking and
you like
and everybody's standing around you're
like go stop go
and then the ball goes straight down the
middle
[Laughter]
and you're always worried like is there
a magnet down there
yeah yeah yeah and that's when you're
too small you're too small to manipulate
the actual machine and tilt it a little
bit
right i never right
you literally
and then the ball everything will stop
and the ball will go down because they
they knew yeah yeah
i'm so glad i'm not old
i'm so glad
i can't imagine what it like
look like you guys
are in that golden area that's fine you
keep that gold in there
you put you put a fence around that
golden air you treasure that i don't
want in the kingdom i don't want to
round the kingdom i don't care i'm not
going to take any taxi to the kingdom of
the stories that helped get the games
used
the smile on his face
do you see the do you hear the richness
of the story yes you want in just you
just can't get it you just it's
impossible
i'm gonna put it around
that's fine it's all good look like what
would you guys talk about the old stuff
that i i'm literally looking into a
black abyss
and uh like i don't know you guys are
like like
owlette like he you know he brought up a
bunch of different games and no
disrespect to the games but i'm like i
don't know what that game is
he's like this game's pretty much these
two games combined it's like well i
don't know what the the two games are
[Laughter]
well we're gonna have to we're gonna
we're gonna set up something new for
patreon we gotta make we please
so we can learn but continue lord said
we got to get these these great stories
you would continue yeah
yeah so you see that you know that
social context right um and so that was
real important um but the next stage for
me i was after elementary school i
actually went to boarding school okay
okay um and i went pretty young um so
yeah my mom won
you know like you know given everything
i just talked about she wanted to get me
out of it yeah
because there was a lot of stuff going
on yeah
and um so i went to boarding school
starting at age 11.
uh in seventh grade so real young really
um there were a lot of boarding high
schools yeah and then i went to a place
called eaglebrook which is an all-boys
junior high school uh in deerfield
massachusetts yeah uh
and
so yeah
well yeah we share that experience we
share that the the boarding school
experience all right am i allowed to ask
questions here like yeah oh i have a
hundred percent yeah so so tell me about
your experience i'm a little curious
oh so uh i have friends that went to
eaglebrook um that later on went to high
school with me and i attended saint
paul's
oh
[Laughter]
if you want that information out there
it's fine i mean it's it's it's there
let's pause that you went to a school
called evil brook
like i'm just sitting here like that's
why i double checked
so the friends that uh that attended
eagle brook were wrestlers
and they continued they continued that
at st paul's and yeah so uh i don't know
if you want me to say the school
i mean yeah i don't know if you should
name names
no no no not people's names no yeah
right right right yeah right
um but yeah so yeah so here we go in
saint paul's uh i was there 91 to 94. oh
right on okay so i'm coming i'm a little
a little a little before yeah yeah yeah
but right on so you understand what i'm
talking about um
so at eaglebrook um it was pretty much
on the commodore 64 still um my big
memory then was the ultima four ultima
uh i i sort of went from bard's tale
into ultimately the computer
role-playing games and i actually had
the opportunity um many years later to
interview and meet lord british
um
who had developed that series he lived
down in austin texas um so ultima 4 was
probably one of my you know main seminal
gaming experiences growing up because
what they did with morality and the
choices you had to make in that game
between different competing moral
imperatives was really important to me
um and so after eagle brook i then went
to a competing school that saw i went to
i went to a school called andover uh
which is a boarding high school okay
one moment
no you're good you're good i like oh i
like that nine is glass but you put that
back up
i like that
i like
for a second okay so i just started you
know at microsoft in march yes and you
know i moved out here pretty quickly but
at the beginning i was on some calls and
teams
and i was insistent on my water glass
forever it should be as it should be
and okay let's stop bleeding the witness
look at you i had i had i'd sort of not
realize or forgotten and one of my more
senior executives and he calls me and
says i gotta talk to you about something
i'm in trouble now he's like you know i
had respect for you before but i
actually have more respect for you
seeing you rock the niners glass because
this is a seahawks company in a seahawks
town this is an nfc west situation out
here so uh yeah i'm still rocking the
house and i don't know
what your chances continue so i just it
was a great choice it was beautiful
so uh you know getting into high school
um the uh the next regret i had gotten
the commodore 128.
um and that was like the 80 characters
across and it was sort of like the end
this is like ninth grade 10th grade
and i had sort of my final programming
experiences uh was that i was into like
you know hippie music and classic rock
so i got into let's
i was really deep into led zeppelin and
the the four members of led zeppelin
have these like weird little symbols
that reflect each member of the band and
i made a screensaver from my commodore
128 with these like hippie symbols of
the members of led zeppelin that would
like bounce around the screen off of
each other with the physics and like you
know with all these like hippie colors
going
um but that was it for me
uh you know uh but as a gamer and i'm
sure you didn't like walk through that
cloud by mistake
you got
[Laughter]
[Music]
and um so in that dorm
there was i mean there were a lot of
rich kids at school but there was one uh
particular kid who had a mac sc that's
my first time seeing them okay and the
sc was the one with the two floppy
drives and then you had like the the
shoebox size hard drive on the side yes
um and that was like and i was like you
know that was my first time seeing a
graphical interface um and the games
weren't that uh incredible but you could
sort of see the the promise there yeah
even though it was all black and white
but the other side was super important
was beginning to get into
wide area gaming um with the people that
weren't they weren't sitting there so
in the at the high school you know as
sophomores you have a lot of resources
very fancy library and a pretty fancy
computer lab this is the late 80s and
there was a computer lab in the basement
of the library that had like 30 macs
and they were all you know on apple
talks and you can print your papers and
stuff and all the you know kids love the
max yes but in the distant corner let's
go uh there was one dusty ibm pc let's
go with dos all right that no one wanted
to use the people who like ran the
computer center didn't even care about
it but there was a dos you see on the
corner that had a modem um
all right and that was we weren't
allowed to have phone lines in the dorm
room right right um but there was one
dos pc in the corner that had a modem on
it and you know we'd all seen war games
at that point right right right
i want to get into that yeah right now i
was like oh i want to get on the modem
right
and i had one friend who was a day
student so he was able to have a
computer at home and he knew what was up
and he taught me how to use dos and we
got on we got on this thing with the
modem and you know we would set up like
hidden partitions so that even like the
administrators wouldn't know what we
were really up to
on that computer
because you having no tv has
you noticed how it creates ingenuity
resourceful yeah
absolutely king you let him have a pc so
he learned the ways of the force yeah i
love it i love that secret partition
getting on that modem
and on the modem we could get on
bulletin board systems you know bvs's
and this was a part of the country where
there's a lot of that and now all of a
sudden you're now communicating with
other real people yeah now it's sort of
early you know message boards yes uh and
you're now you're dealing with other
other folks and it's like it's you know
blowing your mind wow and that was the
beginning of wide area gaming that's
good because we would play games like
trade wars now do you remember something
called fido net i do not but you got it
right so the way that like the different
bbs's would communicate in fact i mean
we had long distance uh telephone
charges right right like you know you
got on the phone if you called outside
your local area you were paying by the
minute get off the phone you're running
up the phone right
but in your local area you can you know
call unlimited yes right and so you can
get on you stay on the bbs all night um
but there was no if you wanted to talk
to somebody in california you know
calling california was just
prohibitively expensive yeah so fidonet
was a network where the bdss could
communicate and transfer files from one
to another with these overlapping local
calling areas wow
so they would literally like send a
message from one and then it would call
the next one 30 miles down the road
which is a local call for that one send
the message call the next one 30 miles
down the road so it was all local hops
right right right so no one was running
up along this nobody's doing a long
distance yeah yeah it's called store and
forward networking okay um so it wasn't
real time right but you could send a
message over fido net that might get
across the country in a day or two
and so within the game
like pass it out
yeah
it's like hot potato
but the games right now you're playing
games with like trade wars sort of like
these science fiction star trek type uh
exploration games where you get one move
a day right everyone would send in their
moves right because you're moving your
your you know your flotillas and your
spaceships around and then the next day
you'd check in and it would have like
synced up got yourself uh let me tell
you right now that would kill this
generation
literally the fomo that they would have
the
yeah i mean maybe i'll be more
productive too
a whole lot to do man maybe i'll get
more stuff though
continue
no no but yeah but at least there's real
people right right it's not real time
but now you're sort of part of something
broader yes um and i never got into uh
aol or genie because i was doing the dvs
stuff right right um and they'd have all
kinds of different you know shady
software you could download and whatnot
um but that was uh so that was you know
important for me um went to college uh
in 1990 okay and
uh that's where we discovered the
internet right um because back then you
know there was no graphic there was no
web right and the only way really to get
on the internet was either to work in
the military or to be at a university
situation correct where you could um so
i showed up
at college in connecticut
uh and that my school had all these unix
mainframes and uh vms have you shout out
to college connecticut i got connecticut
peeps i'll just if you want to if you
would no no i went to yale okay cool
uh uh in new haven new haven yeah
but uh unix hadn't even taken over yet
they still had uh dec dms mainframes uh
as well but unix was clearly taking over
and so what you could do is they would
let you have a phone line and he could
dial in i remember literally walking up
to what we call science hill okay at
yale because they you know it wasn't
this new student orientation was like
yeah there's the computer lab over there
go print your papers over there they
weren't even trying to get the kids onto
the text-based internet um and i
remember like literally walking up
science hill to go to the computer
science department just to ask them hey
like what do i need to do uh to uh to
dial in and get in on this and they're
like why do you want to know
wait breaking protocol
[Laughter]
i can't remember i remember what i said
but all of a sudden now uh and i gotten
on mac at that point um i'd gotten i'd
gone from commodore to mac um but you
weren't i wasn't really running games on
the machine now you're just dialing in
and it's all just uh telnet you know uh
yes text based but you know all the
stuff you know discovering email
usenet news groups sort of the
predecessor to you know reddit or
whatever you call it um for global news
groups and i was always really into
hippie music so i was on the grateful
dead uh news group as well as the you
know the gaming ones um but you could
telnet right into another computer
and there was um
a group of games called mods um
multi-user dungeons otherwise known as
multiple undergraduate destroyers
[Laughter]
and so you know we had all grown up
playing a certain type of game called
you know text adventures right infocom
games like you know adventure zork where
you type you know go east go north you
know attack dragon whatever yeah but
some of them you know really detailed uh
and whatnot but they're all single
player right like you know offline
and you start playing these games called
muds and so you tell them that i
remember telling you into this computer
um in the texas a m university a game
called darker realms all right these are
tech space adventures and you sort of
log in you make a character it says you
know you're in a church with a sword you
know get sword go south go east and to
me it just looks like a normal uh single
player
uh adventure right i'm like oh it's
bigger on another computer and i
remember i'll never forget probably one
of the most important moments in my
personal gaming history
is i just started you're sitting in a
tavern okay and you're just sort of like
this you know and
you're sitting there and all of a sudden
it just pops up a green elf enters the
room
so what looks like in real time you're
sitting there waiting it says green
elephant room
and it says the green elf says hi
what what
excuse me what and um and
and you're like what ah and
says you know the green elf says like
how you doing
this had to blow your mind at the time
could you imagine you said
you know like
that's a real that's a real person yes
[Music]
that was like mind blown like there was
a real person like hey are you doing are
you a new player like yes i'm a new
player like hey do you want to go like i
was like wait like what what and they're
like and they say all right let's go
kill you know the orc down the road i'm
like okay it's like you know he said go
east and i'll be there and then says the
green elf leaves the room with the
easter egg
and then you type go east and the guy's
still there you're like
mind-blowing
totally mind-blowing yes
so long story short my undergraduate
career was not quite destroyed
i imagined get some work done
super deep on you know these mmos i'm
sorry they weren't called mm-hmm yeah
they were they were called mods
tech space but here's the thing right it
was all about the community yes of
people and there's two aspects i want to
highlight number one was the way these
games were set up
was that once you got to like max level
you became what's called a wizard and
once you're a wizard you could create
new areas in the game yourself oh wow
once you've reached max level it would
literally unlock a scripting language
where you could start to create new
areas in the game
so in in my game darker realms there was
like a star trek themed area and a star
wars area and a doctor who area in a
lord of the rings area
and an edgar allen poe area that had
been coded by different players so the
game itself is constantly growing you
know it's almost like a roblox type
situation yeah or a manta core type
situation the creative tools here
impressive other side it was just as
important once again is about the
community right you've got people from
all over the country who are now playing
you know largely from academia who are
playing these multiplayer games but like
you know there was no graphics on the
internet there was no way to send a
picture you know the bandwidth was so
low but people will find a way to
connect yeah right
and so one of the things i wanted to
show you was the darker realms yearbook
oh wow wow
and so what people would do is literally
say hey here's an address send in
pictures of themselves
right like to a physical address where
somebody who ran the game would then put
the pictures together into a physical
stories from the game and then mail back
out to the players that is so cool
and what that showed me was you know
there was no way to see if that's the
first time seeing pictures the people
you were playing with right couldn't
ever hear their voices um but people
will find a way to make community
through gaming right and look and darker
realms are still running my character is
still there um they were in a number of
darker realms you know weddings and
children and whatnot but so that's my
point right is that it's all about we
talk about you know bringing the joy and
community of gaming to everyone on the
planet you know we all saw it yeah you
know in different ways whether it's in
the arcade whether it's you know through
a yearbook um and so that was what
really students showed me at first at
that time you know how important the
community came in
that is powerful you just blew my mind
with that like
the only i i can't relate to that level
because obviously you're there
when this kind of this boom is happening
but it reminds me and saw me know this
one um remember the grail quest books
off
right and it's like yeah it would kind
of like choose your own invention but
they were like you know you create this
world and you know you turn you know you
do this you create your character and
it's go here go east go left but it was
it was base it was in the structure of a
book right of a book and a and a table
top and a table top right but like what
you're saying is to me that equivalent
next level online text base with a
community like
that is mind-blowing so like you say
like
game touch kojima as well
because if you think about it
he was making a game in that manner that
was the original strand game
[Laughter]
you really got to think about it like
everything has a genesis point right
everything has a a point of entry right
your awareness for when that elf walked
in
was mind-blowing to that extent right
yeah and i'm pretty sure that other
people had that same experience and then
when you reach max level and you're
making these worlds you're not really
crafting these worlds for you you're
giving a piece of yourself to the world
but you're crafting the world for the
other player to walk into said world
and
that's that's the expansion that's
exactly what everyone is looking for in
order to share a piece of their self uh
online to everyone else right and like
like you said you had different era star
trek i would have been in a star trek
like a star wars a star trek area and i
would have been over there all day long
but that that is that's key because
individuals took the time out made it to
max level yes it had the same experience
that you did and decided to make a world
craft around that that is so beautiful
so seth did you make any did you make
any expansions to it or that wasn't i
never got to that level i mean because
you really had to be a real programmer
so i was just you know after the the led
zeppelin screenshaver that was it yeah
i was done that was good
i did tell you that he didn't destroy
his undergrad so yeah you had to destroy
that truth
would have
but i'm a wizard though but the thing
about is what is so amazing to me it's
the the precursor like the way you
describe that is the way
like xbox live going online for the
first time was for someone like me right
where it's like wait a minute that's a
real person i'm interacting right so to
me it's like a touch point and it's just
so cool because you know
these are those inflection points in
gaming where you're like okay something
is changing
dramatically in the scope this is
mind-blowing and i really want to salute
you on that that story was powerful my
experience with that what he's talking
about that his my green elf yeah was
x-band i remember
when i put in the x-band and i put the
modem is i really you know okay so
uh
when they to give you the description of
something but execution is totally
different right so so to hit on the
execution of what they give you in the
description sometimes i said a miss
right so you're like it's a gimmick but
then when i when i you know put the
modem in
and i'm playing this guy called showtime
we would play every night
on uh nba live mm-hmm e-a send the game
in the game
we will play
and
it would it was amazing yeah until my
mother picked up the phone
shout out to that
motive
she ran into the she ran into my room
she thought aliens was coming because of
the fault
she said baby
the aliens are here
that's definitely like an error that i i
i can't i hate that i was part of man
the dial up there yeah i was like right
there on the asset of it man
like man i i
that's definitely one thing i wish i
would have avoided yeah like come on
like out of all this stuff that because
because i i missed out because of tech
because before i was born in the
technology technology line like man why
couldn't i have just a little bit man
little bit just missed that dial
it's ridiculous
it gives you texture it gives you it
gives you an appreciation of what you
wear what you went through
talking about that texture man you get
that tape
is talking about reading text and
somebody walks in the green country
that's insane right that's actually
fearful a little bit like part of me is
like
and he's like meet me up the road so we
can kill him
you know there's still like certain
places that do dial up
but i want to get back focus with seth
with him to finish up his history with
the gaming because this is tremendous so
again you do that you're completely
invested in this whole new world it's
open to you as far as connectivity as
far as gaming you know kind of thing so
did that affect the the academia sir did
that well okay i'll cover that but i
want to come back some of the king said
that was super important about this you
know collaborative storytelling let's go
yeah and where it started because it
really started you know with things like
dungeons and dragons in the early 70s
with we have a pen and paper right yeah
this idea of collaborative story
that we're all going to be telling a
story together yeah um you know with a
game structure uh to give it some you
know some uh some balance
but that was really you know the folks
like gary gygax and dave arneson the
inventors dunnons and dragons
and one of the great pleasures of my
career at the times which we'll get to
later because i was actually able to
write uh gary gygax's obituary
um and also an appreciation of him as
the inventor of guns and dragons but
it's really about how we've used
technology right to intermediate yes uh
you know so instead of having to have
you know eight people around a table you
know we can use the technology to do
that in the wide area yes um but those
human uh relationships are stay the same
no matter what the intermediate
intermediate uh technology is um so can
i just want to follow up on that point
sounds tremendous
um so yeah it's coming back to the
narrative um a lot of darker realms as
an undergrad
um
didn't uh you know i was playing some
single player stuff um you know mostly
uh like single-player rpgs but
um
i thankfully did not allow it to uh
poison my academic situation too much um
at that point so i
the other side of the narrative is i
started working on my high school
newspaper when i was at andover
um started working on my college
newspaper at the yale daily news pretty
much the first day of undergrad so i was
always into journalism
and sort of back then at least like the
way you would do that professionally
with youtube summer internships
um so i did uh my first summer
internship was uh after freshman year at
the new orleans times picayune okay uh
you got an 18 year old in new orleans
all summer
on their own
oh that was
you made it past woodstock you can do
this no no no no no nola is different
bro yeah i know i know
different that wasn't a
area with a bunch of high schoolers and
he had to navigate those rough waters to
get to set video games and listen i'm
pretty listen it turned out great well
let's go yeah yeah continue taking all
this different the other the other thing
is i actually saw the grateful dead uh a
hundred times before jerry garcia even
died and i was 22. so yeah i was out on
the road seeing a lot of live music as
well um
which was a you know interesting
environment for teenagers back then yes
um
so but i was doing the journalism thing
just to sort of you know keep that that
thread up um yeah and then went to the
boston globe
for a couple of summers um
graduated in 94 like many
kids didn't really know what to do with
myself so like the defaults go to law
school okay um
so i went to yale law school uh for a
year and i ended up dropping out now
that year at yo law school 94.95 yes
that's when you started to see the web
yeah right yeah like so we had been on
the internet and i remember hearing
rumors so i had actually lived in boston
with these uh mit and harvard grad
student guys who were in like you know
uh biomechanics and all kinds of crazy
science and they were telling me like no
no they're making this thing for the
internet where you can like click the
picture and you click the picture and
it'll take you to another thing like you
don't type anything
that sounds crazy um so just as i was
starting law school was when we started
discovered mosaic and escape
and so
yes i guess it was like mosaic uh first
um
and look i mean it's on a personal level
um
for me i think a regret was i didn't
take time off between undergrad and law
school got you um and i stayed at law
school in the same place i had been in
undergrad so i was just kind of burned
out frankly yeah um and you know
i'm not gonna blame the internet because
it wasn't like oh i was addicted to the
internet instead of going to law school
um but you know i was if that's when you
start you know coding your own home
pages in html oh yeah
uh and sort of discovering uh that the
gaming hadn't really taken advantage of
it yet you know you're still doing
mostly text based uh at that point
drop out of law school in 95 go back to
the uh boston globe uh was an editorial
writer there
um
for a year writing about politics and
policy right um
96 i wanted to be in new york because
all my friends from college were in new
york
1996 that's when new york is super cool
mm-hmm
let's go it was yeah it was fun time i
mean it was like look the world was at
peace right it's sort of like you know
post cold war the dot com boom um people
are first getting cell phones yeah um
but when i went to the times so i
thought i was going to be a politics
writer um my whole life
this is my favorite part right
there baby
okay iconic
really really quickly for people that
don't know the people that don't read
newspapers all right for you guys then
it's a large segment of you guys that
don't read newspapers at this moment in
time uh newspapers is very huge to me so
when we were having stuff on um
it's it's a big aspect for him
so when we talk briefly about it uh i
was so intrigued by this aspect of it
because i'm at one end of the spectrum
and he's at a totally different end of
the spectrum but the new york times is
very serious in new york city massive
it's it's prestige yes
yeah yeah it's pretty much because what
you got the no at the time was news the
post
but the times was oh it was just above
it there's
the iconic reputation of quality the
highest level so king integrity yeah
it's it's a different distinction that
yeah if you're in new york people know
the papers had levels yeah yeah okay so
you see a guy walking down the street
and he has a new york times yeah that's
a different type of dude yeah that's a
different type of dude
that's a different type of person yes
and somebody's picking up the daily news
or the inquirer
it was a culture is it something that
came it's a prestige
yeah the new york times boston globe
those shows yeah it was it hit different
continues
to separate the papers different
continue continue this is this is great
this is great yeah i know so i thought
that i was going to be a politics
fighter i was you know i was one of
those kids who could rattle off 98 of
the 100 senators sort of off the top of
your head wow wow um well coming from
the you know from the boston globe and i
went to this whole interview process
and i thought that my career was going
to be you know
cops city hall go to washington you know
foreign capitals do the whole politics
thing and my whole gaming and internet
thing was just off to the side i didn't
think it had any relevance uh
professionally
and but my uh so i go through this whole
interview process to become a cub
reporter on the metro desk um at the end
of this whole process you're in the this
final interview with the executive
editor the entire newspaper
a guy named joe lillyville at the time
um and the thing is my resume had an
email address and a home page on it okay
which was really rare back then um like
that you would have those things on them
and
the the executive editor of the paper is
looking at my resume
it's like oh you got an email address so
like yeah he's like
he's like this internet thing at the
bottom it's like you could see it about
this internet thing right
i was like yeah i know about the
internet thing he's like well in that
case
how would you like to help cover the
telecommunications industry for the
business section okay wow and to me that
was like greek that was like i had no
idea what he was talking about right
because i i would throw out the business
section i was a politics guy right yeah
it was intimidating for me back there
yeah i wasn't interested in the business
section but i was like yeah sure
whatever whatever and the
telecommunications industry
at that time now we're talking about att
uh there was no verizon back then right
it was 9x 9x
and so not to get too deep in all this
stuff but uh congress had just
deregulated that industry uh the telecom
back to 96 which really opened up a lot
of the things that we experienced now in
terms of just the business and legal and
regulatory structure of that industry
and it was that it was the hottest thing
in the world um and i just lucked into
it
because the telecom in my very first
story so actually just two days ago um
was my 25th anniversary of when i
started at the new york times oh my
my my first day at the new york times
was october 15 1996. yes it was
literally 25 years ago plus two days
right wow so you walk but that industry
um you know for the next few years was
the hottest industry on the planet with
i don't remember like mci worldcom oh
yeah att split up again that's where
verizon came from verizon was the merger
of bell atlantic and
but it was all based on my very first
story was about a new transcontinental
fiber optic network that was being built
to transport all this new data that was
coming up because
you know networks used to be built for
phone calls yes yes not for huge amounts
of data um and so to be able to
participate in covering and i learned a
tremendous amount had incredible
uh mentors um there um my first front
page story was a few months later in
december 96 about this big extension of
copyright law for the first time to the
internet right so that book publishers
movie companies music companies could
feel like they could distribute their
information on the internet and
copyright law would protect that that
wasn't sure that wasn't assured right um
so to have the opportunity to really see
the the rise of wireless uh packet
switching at an infrastructure level and
you know you're covering these huge
companies you know 30 50 80 billion
dollar merger takeovers um so as a young
person i'm covering ceos who are old
enough to be my grandfather
um at that time through my and these
gray hairs are not from age
[Laughter]
they are from competing against the wall
street journal in my 20s
that's the other prestige yes
paper the wall street journal yes so at
that time you know we were just battling
it out you know every day not to get
scooped
on the next big you know merger deal um
so i was able to learn a lot about big
business at that time
the the the video games for me so i
finally around that time made the switch
from mac back to pc okay right because
you at that time you know now we're
getting to the cd-rom era we're getting
into the cd-rom area like wing commander
yeah
epic game classic game and you're
starting to hear about the early
shooters right doom
quake and but what would happen is those
games would come like six or nine months
later to mac yes right and i don't wanna
get into the whole you know mac pc thing
back then but you know mac the apple
went through a lot of different
iterations yeah
it was it was kind of a war yeah i mean
they went to power pc you won yeah
fair enough right yeah well i would
start seeing these you know back when
compute the computer magazines were like
this thick still right yes and you start
seeing the first dedicated 3d graphics
cards you know 3d effects
cards
exactly right yes okay so now now you're
entering where me and sovereign was
playing around for a little bit and you
still you know live in that world of pc
i it's too rich for my blood um i had to
step away from it but let's get to these
video cards where no more little elf
pops and you see the little elf
and he's waiting
and he's waving at two frames per second
but
[Laughter]
no but it was like the first time right
i mean getting that first person
perspective yes yeah and i you know i
was tired of waiting on mac for another
nine months every time so i finally got
a dell i got i got a dell back and
what's that 95.
maybe 6.97 so right around that
um and you know getting into the video
card situation um
and uh so yeah uh so that was absolutely
on the side that's when i started
becoming a big blizzard fan uh the
original original warcraft human boy
uh warcraft ii um the original diablo
uh you know super deep um
and then uh in diablo 2 so yeah all
during like my 20s um you know doing the
the business reporting uh and at night
you know in diablo 2 just you know doing
run after run after run yeah you know
getting those stones and jordan rings oh
yeah the
the whole thing that's good um you know
started you know a little uh little
warcraft online uh with warcraft three
and whatnot yeah um but it never
occurred to me as part of my job i did
write a couple of video game stories
here and there uh in the business
section i actually i think i first wrote
about uh a young ceo of a company called
activision oh and uh bobby codex wow 99
but bobby's
uh just just a couple little things like
you know holiday for the game business
but it wasn't like my day job right
right um so after doing the telecom
stuff uh for a long time i ended up
covering the big media companies aol had
bought time warner
uh so i was covering aol time warner
disney news corp uh vivendi bertelsmann
and this well this french media company
called the vendi
uh wanted uh ended up buying uh nbc and
universal but they also bought sierra
online yes um which owned davidson
associates which or davidson had bought
blizzard right so this french company
vivendi ended up owning sierra which
would make king's quest
quest
remember they they were a publisher at a
period of time right yeah yeah vivendi
universal publishing and they owned a
bunch of including blizzard and stuff um
and didn't really work out that well for
them but i was covering all that uh from
a business perspective right um and then
right around uh
right i guess right after 9 11 a couple
years later um i then left the business
section so i've been there for seven
years at this point
and i hadn't had to go
uh
oh i'm sorry one story that i forgot was
i actually wrote this is right before
monica lewinsky hit um
i had the lead story in the paper
introducing a brand new technology
called digital subscriber line
technology
that was huge it was a front page story
saying you know a consortium of phone
companies and networking companies like
this little startup called cisco
let's go
and all the telecom manufacturers but
this is the idea was this was the first
time that we could get office caliber
yes connectivity connectivity to the
home big game that was that was his mind
no longer remember on the modems we got
from 9 600.
there was a 56 56k motors and that's
where the that was the max was where it
maxed out yes that was really the almost
the theoretical limit of the twisted
pair for copper infrastructure that it
was created by the phone companies right
right
um
and so dsl was a big deal so i wrote
about that and like literally i think
the monica lewinsky scandal hit like two
weeks later right and so that you
weren't going to get on the front page
again yeah you're done
that took over the news cycle right yeah
so um i had done all that um still
playing on the side
i had earned the right i had the gray
hairs at that point i didn't have to go
cover a war i didn't have to go cover a
presidential campaign i'd sort of earn
the right to get a little bit of a cushy
feature job okay and after seven years i
was kind of burning out um and my
editors recognized that so i went to a
stand-alone technology section that we
had called circuits okay
um
and circuits was a consumer tech section
on thursdays that became thursday styles
a lot of gadget coverage this is before
the dot com advertising
yeah
i know what you're talking about yeah
and i started doing some uh some stuff
there and that's when i started writing
about video games a little bit more
um not full-time yeah that's what i was
gonna ask you how did it transition for
you yeah yep so in the once i was in the
consumer tech section i think the first
game that i really wrote about
specifically was a classic rpg called
planescape torment oh
landscape torment classic single player
rpg one of the best written games of all
time
um and i believe it had been published
by interplay i want to i want to get
right into play remember
online yeah i remember them guys yeah
interplay didn't that the people that
qb saw uh not ubisoft obsidian turned
out to be yeah a lot of the same yeah
they split up
and black yeah southern california
southern california single-player rpg
folks um
and there was some a lot of overlap i'm
not going to get it right with all the
different
studios but i did a big story about a uh
not a big story but an article about a
game called planescape tournament and i
got to know the pr person for interplay
okay um now at that time i was starting
to play my first real graphical mmo okay
um i did not play everquest um but you
know going from those text-based muds
into the graphic i heard about everquest
um but i was i was sort of fantasied out
i want to try something a little bit
different so my first gen mmo that i got
deep into was a game called anarchy
online okay
anarchy online it was it's still sort of
around from a company called funcom out
of scandinavia
um and that was a fantastic game um and
that was a real graphical mmo with a lot
of world pvp base building
um and i had gotten into that and i
actually uh you know deep you know a few
nights a week and i wrote a big story
um
about some players in that game
and they didn't like the game they
didn't like the story so they doxed me
um
and i got obviously i basically got docs
out of that game
and uh it was a good learning experience
for me honestly
um i think i didn't think i'd done
anything wrong yeah but it was a good
learning experience for me because i had
spent my previous journalism career you
know writing about at the time about
these ceos and big companies yeah and
people who are sort of you're used to
being in the public eye right um have pr
staffs and everything and i wrote a
story about some you know real people
and i i needed to be reminded when
you're when you're writing about real
people who aren't you know
professionally out there yeah um that
you know maybe you can be a little bit
more sensitive to sensitivity right
they're not used to sort of having their
life sort of put on display right so i
had my my first mmo was anarchy online i
had stopped playing that
uh wrote this thing about uh lanescape
torment and then the pr person from that
went to blizzard okay and i had been a
blizzard fan on that so i wasn't paying
attention to the world of warcraft beta
right right um i had heard about it but
i was sort of like burned out on mmos i
was like i'm not going back to mmos but
like
i
i i signed it off a couple times
over the uh over the years and got you
know dragged back in
and the uh the the pr person so like a
month before wow came out uh this would
have been
a big thing right now
it's like uh
she sent me the collector's edition like
unsolicited like here's that here's the
box
you know here's the box and here's the
discs
and
he's like this
yeah
yeah
i was like i'm not opening that box
you
i just gotten burned out on mmos i'm
like i'm not playing that like i i don't
i can't get into it yeah but i was like
you know but i'll take the box home but
i'm not gonna open
wow launched on the tuesday two days
before thanksgiving
um
[Laughter]
i had just moved to williamsburg
brooklyn and uh
and i had the north henry street and all
that continued
yeah yeah so i don't remember those
original well i had one of the first
gaming laptops which has been sent to me
to review for circus which is dell had
those xps laptops that were you guys
have a phone book yes remember this yes
yes they were like just thick
and i had like reviewed it um so i had
that and i was supposed to go to new
jersey with my family for thanksgiving
but i was like legitimately sick i had
like some
whatever
yeah so so i could know if i call my mom
she's like don't come to thanksgiving i
don't want you getting everybody else
sick you just stay home i love you
um so now i'm sitting there in the
apartment on thanksgiving morning
[Laughter]
the game had just launched two days
earlier so i was like i'll just give it
a shot
a couple minutes let's go play for like
an hour and then woke up two weeks later
two weeks later
i started so i started playing wow two
days after release
um
and that was all she wrote
see you later
and
seth i had to stop playing that game
when i realized i went to western union
and i put real money to buy gold
yeah
that's where i was at with it
that's when you really have to look at
yourself in the mirror it's like no this
is it right here yeah yeah do it anyway
yes because okay so you needed the gold
to to
because there was elves and stuff like
that people who took up crafting and
they would make stuff and they would
sell it in the open marketplace and the
open marketplace was real money like you
know people can make things and actually
make real money
so i had a friend well
my online wife
gauntlets and stuff like gold gauntlets
and stuff but you know you needed to go
in order to buy the material when you
buy the material you hand the material
over to the person they craft the stuff
right there boom you got like a tier
level four or five uh something boots or
whatever you need a belt that made you
super strong
i really looked at once it was 100 i
will never forget that day it was a
hundred dollars and i said
[Music]
[Music]
i jumped into the rabbit hole with both
feet
i got to give a shout out to my server
as joel and the rube
not a big name server um but it's been
there since uh you know pretty early on
um and the thing is you know you
immediately find though it's the people
that you're playing yes yes and that's
what matters right is you start to find
the other folks who are playing at your
level and you start guilds and you get
into it
and you know sort of max level uh back
then was level 60 in the game um so i
ended up becoming uh the i was the
my main character was a human warlock
alliance level 60 sir i did my research
level well i actually was actually the
first level 60 human on the whole server
uh the first level 60 warlock and one of
the first alliance on the server so i
got super into it
um and what was cool though because i
was you know writing about this stuff so
i was able to sort of oh this is all for
research right this is like work
this is all research he's missed the
work around i love it i love it i love
the justifications
you know we all as gamers when we're
doing too much we always have to somehow
justify oh no this is for work this is
this is part of a project
in fairness though i actually ended up
going out to irvine and i wrote the
first mainstream article about world of
warcraft oh wow um a couple months after
i came i went and visited the company uh
and blizzard back then was about 250
people
in this like nondescript um
in orange county and actually half my
family my father's family um is all from
orange county uh southern california
anyway so i was going out there but i
was able to meet the uh the blizzard
team and the wow team uh you know really
early and they were just struggling to
cope with demand yes um you know they
had hoped uh because everquest was the
king of the hill for mmos
had about 400 000 subscribers
and they had hoped if we can match
everquest in a year
that we're doing great right and like
they hit that in like a week damn
um it was just like well i mean there
were story i mean there were people like
around the corner i mean you look at
some of my stories people would camp out
hundreds and hundreds of people just to
buy world of warcraft yeah yep um
and so i and i but so for the next
couple years um
i was writing about the business but i
was raiding five nights a week uh in
vanilla it was uh you know
40 what we call you know 40 person raids
um so you know molten core black wing
layer uh aq40
um and we were all about you know with
server first uh all throughout you know
the first few tiers all through vanilla
i actually was able to get the first a
full set of tier one armor from molten
core on our entire server
um which i'm still bummed out about i
had to delete it later because we didn't
have the inventory space back then you
had to have multiple sets of armor for
resistances yeah so in encourage we had
to get like a what was the nature resist
gear
uh to fight who ran and like you just
didn't have enough bank space to hold on
so i had to actually delete my tier one
set which i'm still bitter about um
no because listen every time you go do a
raid just like the raids that we do now
some of that stuff doesn't drop and then
it's it's the way we peter out loot it's
not like luke drops for everyone
right so you it's like top dog eats
first let me ask you a question because
i'm completely oblivious to a lot of
stuff yeah like i was lucky to avoid wow
because i saw the addiction between
solving king and i was just like i can't
that looks scary but my question is is
it like like you know how destiny raised
when you talk about these resistances
right is it like a set
that like these set bonuses that were
specific to these activities that really
held value that kind of a deal it was it
what what an up type situation like so
that you had to keep that and you didn't
have enough inventory space and you had
to delete other things that you really
didn't want to even though they had high
value
can you answer that because i might
that's it yeah oh no no no he's talking
about in wow so like uh you went further
than i did right okay um and all i can
talk about when we did raids i just like
i did i didn't do a ton of raids right
because again you had to be invited to
these raids and you know and these
people are going in and it's a huge crew
of people and they're all running in and
you have this your mages on this side
your paladins on this side your warriors
on this side and you guys are all going
in and the healers must heal and keep
everybody alive they're wrong
though the warriors must do damage okay
you know the paladins must give the buff
for the defense and stuff like that but
everybody must be working in unison
right
when they drop the loot
you've you've never been kicked out of a
raid by picking up luke he's smiling
because he knows wait wait wait what you
pick up okay so the loot drops like like
dusty with the chest over you beat the
boss no that that's that loot drops for
you oh wait this is a race for the loot
like you fighting your man to pick up
everybody with the loot you touch that
loot and you are not supposed to
you will see you've been removed
[Applause]
because i didn't know
so i grabbed the stuff off the floor ooh
put it down
like
they text you
i
okay so it's top tier eat first like you
know big dog so he stuff would have been
eaten first okay
so these are rules of engagement set up
before the raid start yes sir wow
seth would say being like stuff like
he's number one he's first 60 stuff like
that seth would say all right i already
got those boots who wants these dogs oh
so he it's a tears it's a hierarchy and
did he get the distributed wow
so the little puppies eat last like so i
was alone
i stuck my hand in the pool like that
and then you got something they call you
ninjas yeah so like if the ninja taken
see i have an obsessive personality if i
was in that environment i'd be the
person saying no that's mine you can
have this you could have that
this is i never knew this i don't know
why i would be that tall cheerful
this is hilarious i am so sorry to
divert that's why i don't know i just
didn't i don't you get it get it i know
i was gonna say that's why i don't be
messing with that that that that i
remember there was one time i almost
played wow and it was because it was for
a female yeah
like i like she i was she was like yeah
you should play wild with me like ah i
guess
thank god it never happened it never
happened no i i don't blame no but this
is very interesting i'm glad
explained this this aspect of it because
i never had anybody that was high enough
or that i can talk to about it terrain
with my language that i'm talking okay
okay and seth understands the lane and
he understands it to a higher degree
because he went a whole lot further
he went a whole lot further than i did
in the game but that whole that's what
really pissed me off as well like when
you do a raid your joint could drop
but if you ain't you know high on the
totem pole
that's not for you
this is important yes um okay so just to
yeah just to amplify what what king is
saying so back then the raids were 40
people okay yep and so you might have
you might kill the monster and there
would be like three or four pieces of
loot maybe three for 40 people and you
gotta figure out who gets it right
and
okay and but the system that we used to
use was called dkp does that name rainey
bill's dkp stands for dragon kill points
and basically what it means is you're
trying to uh incentivize and reward
participation okay so every time that
the group goes and kills the monster or
a big monster or boss everyone in the
group gets one point because you were
there right right right and then so as
you keep doing it if you don't show up
you don't get any points right so
everyone has like a running tally of
points right so then when the loot drops
that you want then it's like you bid a
certain number of points
you would you know spend the points that
you would earn by contributing to the
group right and then when you would sell
those points you would drop down so then
the next person would get it right so it
actually is like relatively fair but
there's some pretty funny memes like
some wild vanilla there's a famous one
from a dragon where the guy is you know
more dots more dots more dots and then
somebody screws up he goes dk 50 dkp
minus right so that means 50 minus 50
dkp dkp minus would be like the radiator
to say we're taking away your points
because you screwed up the encounter wow
i imagine sorry to interrupt you seth
imagine us playing destiny with this
type of yeah i imagine this is
imagine that galahorn drops
now you have to have a double dragon
style face-off to see who gets loot who
last man standing oh yeah
that is when the greediness comes out of
peace
the loot drama is this the flip side is
not only because destiny is six of us in
the raid he's talking 40. so
now you just did this raid and you
you know raider 38 and you need that boo
and you literally it's a participation
show because yo yo what is it dk
business yeah this is actually the
origins of the battle royale this is
where it started
people always say stuff like mario party
mario kart that that is super smash bros
that's the frightening killer what you
telling me yeah this is that's the
killer that's the friend killer but i'm
sorry i said let's give you guys well no
they don't do this anymore i mean this
is why they put in personal loot oh yeah
right this was a pre okay got it got it
they don't do that anymore now like you
know you have your own little slot
machine and you get the loot and only
you can have it you can't trade it good
um because for the social aspect yes um
but yeah also remember this there was no
voice comms back then it was all by text
yeah this was all typing he put it down
[Laughter]
let me ask you a question like keep in
mind this is this is back before there
was like a lot of like ways to social
interact with each other for people on
the internet but fact before forums back
before any kind of uh finders like
something like that happens now i'm just
i'm just lfg and taking my loot leaving
i'm never going to talk to them people
again like this is back in the day where
that kind of accessibility wasn't around
you had to deal with these people on a
day-by-day basis so you couldn't just
take something like there was a server
community right you had a reputation yes
and that was important right yeah if you
were known as a ninja then people
weren't going to invite you into your
group
okay okay because people talk like
literally they like oh hold on i'm
frozen yeah you're good you're good
they're like they literally they're like
oh he's a ninja
you you're not invited because that
means you're a thief
right so literally you're a thief
you're not to be true i am so glad i
missed out on this i'm sorry i had to
divert this this is the most hilarious
thing continue so how did you get how
did you get through this we got we got
we got more to get you yeah sorry
it's my fault i apologize
thank you because i got a chance to talk
about the ninja
the skilling
yeah and i'll try to go a little faster
so yeah uh ton of wow um that's that
section i was writing for uh goes away
in 2005
uh circuits um but that's when the
culture editors came to me and said seth
how would you like to write about video
games not as business not as technology
but as mass entertainment and culture
and that's when i became a full-time
video game right nice i had already been
at the paper for seven years doing this
other stuff and in 2005 a
visionary editor named sam sifton who
sold the paper was running the culture
section
and embraced the idea that we should be
writing about video games just like we
write about books and movies and
television
and other forms of media
so i spent three years uh writing about
sort of that as a reporter
and then i guess with the years right 08
when grand theft auto 4 came out so gta
4 was coming out set in liberty city you
know basically new york um and at that
point uh my boss said you know what seth
take off your reporter hat you can just
become a critic oh uh and i started just
reviewing games um and this was the 360
era
um i had started writing about games in
2005
right when the 360 came out uh reviewed
the 360.
um that's why i started to get to know
people in the business because i had
been a gamer my whole life but i never
got to meet any of the executives or
anything nice so i think i felt i first
met phil spencer i think in 2005
in amsterdam right right before the 360
came out they had like 500 media like a
thousand media from all over the world
in amsterdam for like five days wow uh
to demo the 360. and that was my first
time meeting people in the industry and
the other journalists who are incredibly
welcoming to me nice um a lot of folks
who are still around
um
so yeah then i reviewed games uh all
through the 360 ps3 era uh reviewed the
consoles of the wii era
um because this is as games were coming
back into the mainstream right games
like things like the wii like guitar
hero like world of warcraft we're
expanding the audience again right
so that more people could play
um myself personally at that time i was
playing a lot of wow um sort of stopped
playing well that hardcore when burning
crusade came out okay i did get first
level 70 on my server when burning
crusade came out absolutely but i was
working right i was actually blogging it
yeah um
we uh we crashed the new york times
website a few times
world of warcraft news because they well
they didn't understand right like they
didn't get it like the i.t people i said
sorry so when burning crusade the first
expansion for wow was about to come out
i got the exclusive uh announcing the
new alliance race the trinidad
um it was right before e3
and i we had all these screenshots in an
interview right and we were gonna have
the world exclusive and blizzard was
gonna put it on the wow launcher and
like oh that's you so it's massive
massive exclusive
and i tried to tell the i.t people at
the time you better serve
they didn't know what was about to
happen yeah no they laughed me after uh
we're the new york times like you know
we got lots of traffic
we're used to that they weren't used to
it yeah no the game is very different
we took down the entire ny times domain
for like an hour like you know of all
the traffic coming in for the draenei
announced release um you know six
reviewed games for a bunch for the
culture section so i was there uh uh
total 16 years um my last seven in the
culture section yes let me ask you a
question because you was reviewing games
you're reviewing games for
like uh other companies like nintendo
stuff like that
um
did you have the consoles
all right so you had the consoles right
what was the first console that you got
because you're a pc dude all right so
you know this this this gated uh garden
wall garden
console is there what was your first
console that you had uh because
you mainly game on pc you're used to the
video cards you used to swapping out and
doing all this other stuff this is just
plug and play what was your first
plug-and-play my first that i didn't i
want to answer i will answer the
question specifically but my sort of
seminal console experience and just
going back just a little bit it's like
nes i never had that right right but i
played super mario in the arcade oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so i added some exposure to the ips
the arcade versions right um my first
real crazy console experience was i went
and visited my brother my family in
southern california
he had a ps2 playing grand theft auto 3.
wow
and that was it right yeah
and i had no nothing like that on pc at
that time yeah
so gta 3 on ps2 uh i may have borrowed
his ps2
i may have borrowed
for a little bit to play gta 3.
um but um they sent me an og xbox right
so i started
and i started messing around with it a
little bit but the 360 was just coming
out okay right um a little bit later yep
um so it was really the 360. um
and i was reviewing it but i could
immediately see it was a amp three was
the snowboarding game opening game at
launch
and that big screen experience i will
never forget of playing amp 3 um but it
was also the online it was the xbox what
they had done with xbox live in the
community and i've been an online pc
gamer but i could immediately see that
they had immediately democratized yes
the community and internet experience in
the 360 in a way that playstation wasn't
matching at that time right and it was
so clear to me that that was a leap a
huge leap forward um right there huge
absolutely but king to your point i had
a learning curve and i didn't i never
tried to front i never said i was a big
you know console guy right right uh but
i you know appreciated it for you know
what it is and so i had to dig in and i
had a lot of work to do um to be fair
yeah uh so yeah i went through that
whole pro starting with gta 4 i was
pretty much a full-time critic
um
and
uh the paper really loved it you know
people asked me all the time was the
paper supportive
um incredibly supportive um you know uh
sam sifton and his successors in the
culture section were just incredible
nice um but you know to be honest uh by
around 2012 i've been at the paper for
close to 17 years
and those last
you know four years were basically me in
my apartment in williamsburg playing
video games for 70 80 hours a week
which you know
mid late 30s
and it was a lot of fun um you know many
people's dream job but the walls were
starting to close in on me yeah of
course i needed to get out and try just
a different uh just do something
different um and i had never really
thought i was going to be a new york
times lifer um i just sort of had ended
up in these situations gotcha that were
they you know letting me you know do
really interesting things
so i left the paper in 2012 uh started
working on a startup called fans uh my
uh my co-founder pete shapiro owns a
club called brooklyn bowl in
williamsburg a rock and roll club
um it's a lot of hippie music stuff we
built the world's greatest database of
rock and roll concerts nice um so now
we're into 2012. um i had started
playing eve online uh in 2007. that's a
lifestyle we don't have time for that
right now
um but had this crazy startup experience
but one thing i'll point out
in terms of what got me here to uh you
know right now to xbox
is when i was gonna leave the times um
to do this crazy startup uh one of the
original editors who hired me i asked
his advice guy named john geddes and he
said seth your startup will probably
fail uh most do
um but you should do it anyway because
you will learn so much about business
about other people
about life and about yourself right uh
that you should do it anyway um and so i
had that experience and it was really
great to learn about business yeah
um left that in 2017
um
was basically uh unemployed for a couple
years um
in 2018 though uh i had uh i'll tell ya
my mother died um
in woodstock
um but i was taking care of her for the
last few months of her life and you know
she was uh you know not doing well um
but those months that i was able to
spend back in that basement oh
he took it back to the essence same in
same basement yeah you know now i'm you
know playing europa universal is for i'm
playing wow i'm playing eve while taking
care of my mom uh was a really
meaningful
you know full journey uh around um
and then i guess at the end of 2019 um i
sort of realized that i was trying to
figure out my next step in life i was
like i gotta go back to what i know
uh which is writing about video games
right uh but the game industry remember
i had grown up as a business reporter
covering huge companies right and then i
had been a game critic but i had never
written about the game industry got you
um and you know coming back you know and
i'd been out of this out of journalism
for seven eight years but it was so
obvious that this industry had continued
to expand and to grow
and you start to see all the big tech
companies getting into gaming you know
google with stadia apple with what
they're doing facebook
um
and there was really an opportunity so i
started writing freelance for the times
okay um also for a new publication
called protocol i was just about to ask
you how did protocol come into play yeah
i was just about
yeah protocol is a brand new publication
um that i guess launched at the
beginning of last year time flies um
and they're sort of affiliated with
politico yes and i'd ended up in a
conversation before they launched and
they wanted to do sort of you know
coverage of tech and i was like oh you
should have some video game stuff and
they're like well
what video games what does that have to
do with big tech
and i've gotten very used to giving my
whole song and dance about why
mainstream journalism outlets should
care about the video game business and
how it's how relevant because games are
becoming one of the next great consumer
battlegrounds
for all the big tech companies and so
they said all right well you know why
don't we start off you know with a
couple of stories um and my first story
for them was in february about how all
the big tech companies were getting into
gaming
um and it worked out real well um and
the thing is you know it it's hard to
put this way but you know covet hit a
month later yeah oh man
and
you know we were in new york city you
know i was in new york city i you know i
remember going through it and it was
real rough um but it was you know pretty
obvious that you know locked up at home
people were going to be oh yeah playing
a lot of video games um and it is clear
to the the media as well so all of a
sudden you know i'd spend a couple years
before that you know trying to you know
knock on doors saying hey do you want to
rebuild some video game coverage and not
getting a whole lot of positive response
right uh but all of a sudden uh once
covid hit all these you know editors are
like oh we need articles about video
games
and then the video game business
um but it you know for me it was really
an opportunity to reconnect with folks
in the industry
across different companies because i had
been around and left and come back
um so was able to you know write a bunch
of interesting stuff last year about you
know apple and facebook for the times
and for protocol but i'll tell you the
story that leaps out to me
was the when i first saw the new
microsoft flight simulator yes
uh last summer and i did a story and it
obviously it visually it's incredible oh
but as i started talking to the people
who were making it at microsoft and they
were telling me about how all the
different pieces of microsoft had come
together yes in the service of that
product azure with the cloud computing
and the ai being with the photogrammetry
and the satellites and the lasers
and all this you know big tech that was
going into this product oh yeah it
became so clear to me this was a game
that only microsoft can make yes
with the tech background
the resources and the history in gaming
yeah all together
uh and i was like this is the kind of
you know enterprise that there wasn't a
job on the table i was like oh this is
really interesting because you start to
see different kinds of experiences that
only certain kinds of companies can do
yeah yep uh so uh in october the job
that i have now was publicly listed um
some folks encouraged me to apply nice
um i want to back you up just one quick
second because sure you're dropping like
you set it up beautifully but there is
one thing as for me and i feel like a
lot of
gamers and gamers in the xbox community
i feel like obviously you have this
illustrious career journalism then you
do protocol but i feel like the xbox
community took notice of you
in my opinion one of your greatest
journalistic interviews was with the
game lab keynote
fireside with phil spencer
and it was different because we've seen
phil spencer interviews before
but when you took the platform it was
like this friend he knew for years like
it was already like it wasn't like the
normal interview it was just so well
done so um i just want to know remember
they did have uh a connection earlier
yes because he said you know his first
exact
uh stuff you know phil was there i feel
on the public scale because one thing
about the xyz community you know
whenever phil goes to a platform talk
the xbox community follows
you know so we affectionately here in
the realm of
phil dominance maximus aurelius spencer
as we call him
excuse you sir let me say it yes please
phil dominus maximus i really ass
correct you know and um i affectionately
give him that name and uh
people have a weird uh conversation with
it like it's just weird stuff but i
affectionately give him the name because
he took my
my beloved uh console
and that's solo because you know there's
a football team you know patrick mahomes
is the quarterback and if they lose
patrick mahomes loss
right uh if they win patron holmes won
right but we all know that there's a
whole bunch of people that that that
actually
went into that whole thing so as the
leader of the ship i affectionately gave
him that name every milestone that he
hit and he became the golden one at the
end when he achieved this extra
milestone but when i watched your
interview i really saw a different side
of that it was different it was yeah it
was different it was definitely
different big shout out to the afro seth
that was amazing
we're definitely feeling that we
definitely feel like in all seriousness
king and thanks for bringing that up
obviously because um it was great for me
to reconnect with phil and the rest of
the team but it was so clear to me
that uh he was building a team and an
organization
that had a different uh approach a
different goal and we talk about you
know what we're all about now is
bringing the joy and community of gaming
to everyone on the planet yes and that
is a breadth of goal uh that uh that
phil and the rest of the team is totally
behind and it's a goal that we couldn't
even really have if we weren't uh able
to tap into the resources of microsoft
uh in terms of being able to think
globally and being able to reach people
across different devices different
technologies and different ways to all
bring everyone as possible if they want
to into this global community of gamers
um that was also the interview uh where
they hid the series s
there was so many significant corners
and they trolled me about it two months
later yeah right like
in september they did that on twitter
um but you know it was pretty clear
there was something special going on
here between you know talking to phil um
seeing flight sim so i was encouraged to
apply for this role
um
and uh my final story i guess as a
journalist really well i did some stuff
for protocol but my last story for the
times was actually about sony him
playstation
uh in december um but then i had to go
quiet um
and and here we are um
but you know
thanks for you know letting me tell this
whole story but you know really it's all
about the community and bringing people
together yes and you know the role that
i have now is really about helping
amplify others voices
um you know we you know communicate in
different ways about our business um i'm
also involved with how we communicate
internally yes um with the thousands of
people uh incredibly dedicated folks on
team xbox in the end of the day i voted
with my feet
right uh you know i i had other
opportunities and i came to the place
where i felt like i could work uh with a
team uh of folks at every level uh that
really is all about bringing that joy
and community of gaming to everyone yeah
uh and it's incredibly fulfilling to be
able to be a part of it yeah i just
wanna um you know it was a huge
announcement and i do remember that
magic moment and got a quote she has a
great quote from there you said
interactive entertainment is the world's
most dynamic industry and gamers are a
force of good that's why i'm so thrilled
to join team xbox as director of
executive communications together we
will continue to extend the joy and
community of gaming to people everywhere
so it was a big deal you know we saw
everyone's giving you kudos the respect
was there and then um again my question
i guess so like we know obviously you're
still fairly new to the role but like
what's your overall excitement and for
the future and direction of the xbox
brand
my future excitement is that we can
bring more people
into gaming yeah and we can bring down
the barriers whether that's range of
content uh xcloud i've got my xcloud mug
right here
you know we're seeing incredible take up
in different parts of the world it's all
about letting people come into gaming in
the way that works for you right you
know on the devices you already own um
so we're not just a little click you
know off to the side of entertainment um
i love the diversity of business models
uh in this industry just from a business
perspective you know we can do things in
different ways to get things in people's
uh in people's hands but really it's
about enabling creators that that
breadth of experience and then letting
players everybody participate because
whenever one plays we all win absolutely
now the other question that is a
follow-up i got to be honest a lot of
stuff like i feel in the past
xbox communication has at times been a
little shaky
just a little bit you know so it just
mixed in past generations right so i
guess like however i do feel
in the xbox series era there's been a
tremendous improvement right so any
specific things that you want to target
with this new role as far as like just
kind of changing that culture just
fostering that kind of level because
again i feel series x has been
it's been a different level of
transparency even with the level of from
the feature set and what's going on with
gaming and stuff the things that they're
doing you know obviously we've had um
the legend you know jason ronald on and
you know talking about the launch and
things of that nature so just as far as
like anything specifically you would
hope to accomplish during your your
tenure
sure well first of all it's really it's
a sign of you know we need to be uh take
seriously people care right at least
people are you know these people are
interested right and look we know as
gamers that that relationship between
gamers and the company that makes the
game can be difficult being a sports fan
right like you know when you're a fan of
a team you're probably the biggest
critic of the owner absolutely at times
but just shows that you care right it's
just a reflection of that passion yeah
um so you know every day uh we need to
appreciate that passion that the fans
have mm-hmm uh look i would i just got
here uh six seven months ago so i can't
really speak to what came before yeah um
but i think in general uh as a team we
are
incredibly appreciative of the community
uh and the players that's where it
starts right it's not about us it's not
about it's not even really about the
games it's about the players absolutely
uh and having that respect for the
players um you know learning to admit
when you make a mistake yeah um you know
explain your thinking a bit um
and you know being able to really have
that relationship um is just so
important especially you know in this
business yeah absolutely i think that's
i think that's huge
uh
the level of uh personality that
microsoft seems to have right um each
individual is you can see them as a
person and not just uh you know a
figurehead here or figurehead here just
you know uh giving out and issuing uh
little pamphlets or whatever that
they're issuing and what their talking
points are
it's it's more of um
human yeah to be honest with you the
word human reaches out to me when i
think of microsoft because i've met
these individuals i've had in uh
conversations with these individuals and
uh
very humble very human yes
and and and they're very sincere when
they say that the the player
is the centerpiece here
and how can we reach the player and from
their branch out and it goes back to
your organicness with the elf
right
you're back to that that space and you
see that space and you see how it can
grow into something and i think you saw
the elf again
back when the job was available
you said i can grow in this space and
wonderful things can happen from this
place and that's what i see here yeah
well thanks king i mean just to amplify
what you just said you're totally right
on and
you know uh you know it'll sound a
little bit corporate i guess um but one
of the things that i but i really picked
up right when i was talking to phil
about this role and other folks was that
we're trying to create a workplace here
where people can bring their whole
selves to
work yes and you know be who you really
are
um and make use of all these you know
crazy eclectic experiences that we all
have you know we're not just a list of
bullet points on a resume we're just
actual real people and one of the cool
things about a enterprise with the
breadth of microsoft is that there's
something for everyone right like you
know no matter who you are
like you know all the little quirks in
my background you know are finding
expression in the work i do every day
and you know we try to do that across
the company as far as i've been able to
tell so that personality you're picking
up king is that we expect people to
bring their personality to work and we
want that because we think having the
broadest workforce of people allows us
to create the best products and you know
if our goal is to bring the joy and
community of gaming to billions and
billions of people we need to have a
workforce that you know has a similar
breadth of you know life experience in
order to have to be reflecting
absolutely
to that point seth when you talk about
sort of the breadth of your experience
and and how that sort of
informs the culture at microsoft in
general
what do you think you're you're going
back to the boarding school stuff what
do you think your boarding school
experience sort of added to that because
especially as a person of color because
uh you know for me it was very jarring
at first and and it but it's an
experience i loved that i had because i
would not have
seen sort of i would i wouldn't have had
those experiences otherwise if i stayed
in the city and just around people that
looked like me sounded like me talk like
me um i wouldn't have had those
experiences and been able to sort of
been open to to different things i and i
wonder if your experience was similar i
know andover is a bigger school than
mine mine was you know 500 students
total
perhaps 60 of us were people of color i
know andover had
was bigger and has more was it was it
different for you in that regard or did
it did it also open your eyes to sort of
like
hey
you know i i want to be open to
everything especially coming from the
family you came from with a multi-racial
family but you know with a sort of
hippie mentality you know love is love
love is everything like you know
so how did that how did that sort of uh
experience kind of inform
who you are today
well first of all i've got a lot of
respect for saint paul's i've got a lot
of friends who went to saint paul's so
um but yeah no you put your finger on
something really important uh sof um you
know in woodstock where i grew up i was
pretty much like the only black kid in
the town uh there was like one black uh
girl but i was pretty much the only
black boy in the town but it's supreme
but you know largely hippie town um
going away to boarding school you know
my roommate in seventh grade was from
dubai my roommate in eighth grade was
from taiwan wow
my roommate in 9th grade was from a very
exotic place called new jersey
[Laughter]
but in all seriousness right i mean like
you know for me like one of the benefits
of that boarding school experience was
being exposed to people from all over
the world at a young age yes and one of
the cool things was back then because
there was no internet or phones
uh you didn't really know what people's
background was
like you know you know at public schools
oh the rich kids are over there the you
know the working class kids are over
there what kind of car do you drive at
school you know when you're all together
as kids you don't really know
and the culture back then at least was
like you know the richer the kid like
the more they would like dress and like
right oh yeah
they weren't trying to dress up or
trying to dress down so we were all it
was pretty you know uh pretty even
you know pretty egalitarian
um and it was you know a great time to
you know meet people from you know much
different backgrounds just as people and
you know my friends from high school you
know are among my best friends in the
world uh you know today that said you
know it requires a lot of discipline on
the part of the kid because you know you
don't have your parents they're telling
you what to do all the time
and depending on the school you know you
know they will fail you out right yes
you've got a lot of that personal
responsibility that some people don't
get until college or wherever um but
look at my friends he didn't make it
right in different ways um i have
friends who fell by the wayside because
it was a little too much freedom yeah um
so but you know
thanks for asking about that and um you
know and on the racial side
um you know that's part of it um but i
think you know also you know bring it
back to here i think you know as gamers
you know look there's different types of
toxicity but in general
um i think you know we're incredible as
a global community because we're all you
know together and you can see the
humanity right people from all kinds of
different cultures and geographies we're
all into the same stuff absolutely as
we're getting closer around i want to
make sure addict gets equating questions
you have for seth in
can you guys hear me yeah you know there
you go yeah
yeah you know when it comes to the
communication that um cog was talking
about earlier uh you know one of the
things that
i think that because microsoft's been
very you know transparent with a lot of
things
in the past but i think especially with
the series x and the series s you know
promotion going into it you know i for
first off i think the way you guys you
know just in general how you
communicated with the series snx was was
was on another level entirely and i
think it's the transparency it's like
you know for the most part
you guys say exactly what your thought
process is and what i like is is how
aaron greenberg been here lately like
when an event happens and and then you
see these wild expectations going on on
twitter he goes on to buy five companies
five studios five dabs go get boys back
up
we ain't doing that i know it because
you could tell the thing that i like
about microsoft the most
is i can reach out and touch you guys
yeah in fact in fact you know i don't
get that with a lot of the other people
in the gaming industry because when it
comes to you know aaron greenberg you
know he's like look i i i'm watching the
pod you know you you don't see them but
i'm sure some of them have been in and
out of the iop chat you know that
obviously they're not typing because
they want to be you know they don't want
people bothering them in the chat but
it's like we see that we see the podcast
we see what your guys's expectations are
and you know it's like aaron greenberg
like you know he goes and he sees these
crazy expectations and
back in the day i felt like
they wouldn't correct that [ __ ] they
would just let it hit a wall right but
but now eric greens would like i'm not
gonna let this community get ahead of it
yeah get ahead of what is was not
realistic and i want to kind of tone it
back down to real realistic expectations
and i felt like they're
and
once again eric gerber like when it
comes to stuff that maybe was said that
shouldn't have been said with the game
play a couple years ago like he came out
was like look maybe we did have a little
bit of a miscommunication in terms what
was gameplay what was not gameplay but
we'll do better on that and that's what
i i really appreciate you know the
the the transparency because you just
don't see that a lot especially with
multi-trainer companies like you know
for the a lot of the time it's a lot of
pr speak like i feel like there's a lot
of human going on in terms of what goes
on twitter absolutely absolutely y'all
don't miss a trick um
no because what you just said um is
exactly right in terms of you know first
of all we're really conscious on the
agent on the expectation setting okay uh
you know we want people to have a sense
of you know the level of altitude of any
given situation but when you talk about
greeny or whoever else you see a couple
things i point out number one um we are
like
a part of the community i mean you know
i mean i i watch ilp on sundays
uh uh you know um i won't speak for
other people but you know individually
but you know that's what we do um a lot
of us it's just you know we're just this
is what we do for fun uh in addition to
digital work but then you talk about
sort of that autonomy uh addict you know
it really starts at the top it starts
with phil you know fills the game
and you know because of our
organizational structure you know that
comes you know we have that we get that
from him uh and he encourages us you
know there's lots lots of rules and
expectations but in terms of being
genuine uh in our style um it's because
we come you know it all comes from phil
uh to a certain extent yeah salute
salute i want to show kid before i have
my final question oh can you add
anything you wanted to ask uh before i
get it oh no no um we we hit on all the
points okay he was magnificent in a lot
of aspects i never thought we would get
you know texas deep yeah this is this is
amazing
that's
beautiful
yeah yeah
for me it's just listening to seth's
story
you
you kind of realize like he really had
his hand on the arc of gaming yes yes
from a very early when you think about
the things like the stories that he
broke like dsl and stuff that's huge
that is that is so integral to who we
are as gamers and and honestly as a
society as a modern society with all
these technological advances
to see where you were during different
points of your career in life you really
did have sort of your hand on like in
the mix of everything
it's such an interesting story yeah
i've been very fortunate
what i like about his history
is
you know we've interviewed a lot of
people that have been in the industry
but they've been around other games like
you know seth said that he he like
you have to constantly
doing your your pitch on why people
should cover this why should people you
have to do that a lot before you master
that and he he did it to a point of
talking to non-gamers of why gaming is
relevant yeah and i think we haven't
really come across people like that yeah
you know ryan mccaffrey was uh doing
stuff with other gamers and you know
because they were covering the gaming
industry but he was in new york times
where it's kind of like the
the phil spencer and xbox at the
interviews where they're like oh you
know you guys you don't make no money
you're like you know where he's
constantly that division is constantly
at the validate why we're here why we're
doing what we're doing
we see satchels all in now oh yeah yeah
and then you're giving them a heads up
when he was breaking a huge story that
he knew was a huge story yeah and yo
listen get your site traffic ready
because this is about to go down because
yeah because because in the building
he's in they don't even understand that
that's what's about to happen yeah and
seth is already seeing it i'm sorry
that's what you know i was getting to
it's like it's one thing to be in
something where everyone's in tune
everyone understands what's going on
it's another thing to be in a room full
of people that neither a don't
understand what you're doing they don't
understand what you're writing about or
b they don't respect gaming so they
don't care about it right you have to
constantly
validate why this needs to be written
about why this needs to be covered
absolutely and i thought
that would be
how it would go right i thought honestly
we would be talking about the the
struggle from the inside the new york
times but what you did explain was all
your editors were supportive yeah they
actually were backing your vision and
what you brought across and they trust
in your integrity
because i i don't care what anybody say
uh when you pick up the new york times
for the most part in the wall street
journal you're going into a uh a paper
where the integrity is key yeah right so
you're not gonna read an article you're
not going to read a piece where it's
made up no sources no stuff like that
you're going to actually read a piece
that was well researched well thought
out and it was brought through so
for these individuals to trust in your
integrity to this part and also know
that you're going to finish that great
job in this area and give you full
support
it changed my whole conversation when it
came to your time at the new york times
and it turns from a struggle into
actually a supportive situation that you
went from that when they closed down
this section and when you said new york
styles the styles section
[Laughter]
we fear thursdays right so i'm on the
distribution end and when thursdays come
in and the style section is in there
extra fat yeah
[Laughter]
we fear that so i have to thank you for
putting that fear in my soul because
i've been there for 20 years
i think if i can say one more thing and
it's just the fact that
it's funny coming from me that you know
the single-payers
selfish experience player but i but i i
do come my multiplayer love comes from
sitting on a couch with somebody or
sitting at an arcade cabinet with
somebody playing you know when it when
it went online i lost a little bit of
that fine right
but at the end of the day for seth to
see that at the very beginning of his
gaming experiences and see the
importance of that and and and it speaks
to you know us as mostly older gamers
older gamers
the core of video games the things that
really really make them exciting and fun
to play the core of those experiences
haven't changed even today right what
makes a game great things that make a
game great and and
from the very beginning seth saw that
stuff like the interaction with other
people the gameplay the the thing is
that the core of gaming has not changed
it hasn't
and to be able to see that at such a
young age
and to be able to take those teachings
and learnings from that and still apply
it today and have it matter in the way
that it does is it's kind of bonkers so
to all of you guys that look at us and
like oh that old stuff whatever old
stuff matters it matters exactly all
right it got it to where it is today and
that's why these conversations are
important it's super important i just
want to finish i was like i know we're
right at the edges time we got to get
them out of here but um the one thing i
do respect
yeah respect about you
is that you know regards to your new
role and some comments you made about
communication because your new role is
this communication right and you said in
regards to explaining complex situations
subjects inaccessible terms you state
and i quote of course this isn't really
about understanding the subject itself
effective communication requires deep
empathy for the listener when they're
where they're coming from in the mental
journey you're leading them on that
power can be used to educate motivate or
manipulate so tell the realm if i was
like why
the level of empathy and communication
is so important to you in this role well
you know as we pointed out here it's
really about reaching not only the
hardcore gamers right and like i'm you
know i'm i'm one of the one of us
but it's also speaking to that broader
audience right yes and how do we take
what's great about gaming that we all
know and express it in a way
that the whole world can participate
uh in a way that people can can buy in
and that's what we're really trying to
do here um is extend that joying
community that we all know about to a
broader audience and we'll keep doing
our best and you know engaging with the
community you know closely is a huge
part of that um and you know well when
we screw up you let us know oh yeah you
know i know
we'll talk about it
you know
but it's all about you know staying
humble and uh and you know recognizing
that the community is really where it
all starts uh and that's what we're
trying to do much love
a tremendous journey incredible passion
i mean
the election
used that damn box i knew it
brother it was
said it was absolute pleasure to hear
your journey your story and we just look
forward to the future the futures of
bright i think they've made a tremendous
decision with you in this role i think
it's a great choice and um the final
thing that we got to get you out of here
there's something that we a tradition
here in the realm we cannot let you
leave unless you gloriff gives us his
top five video games or franchises of
all time
yeah let's get it all right um and i
haven't like made this up uh before um i
think i think one of them though is
i think there's some meme on the show um
look there's one video game that will be
played
pretty much untouched 500 years from now
on whatever planet we're on uh and
that's tetris
i know the moment he was talking about
that i was like this man about to say
the perfect video game yeah i i i had to
hit you with the tetris
um
i think uh
i think you gotta give um i think you
gotta give world of warcraft uh the
warcraft franchise uh some credit there
first time let's go um
you know for me i gotta put grand theft
auto franchise
in there
um
uh mario has to be there
just as a franchise um
and i guess you know for me i'll just
give a shout out i mean what i can you
know have long thought is pretty much
the most interesting game around uh is
eve online uh to me
because it's a sandbox of human
experience um in a way that other games
don't so i guess that would be my five
off the top of my house and i'm
forgetting somebody who we know you're
because you already know what your
answer is we know you're yeah we know
you're a pc guy with a halo by the way i
can say hello oh yes you can say hello
yes you can as you go
as far as um you know pc is your
backbone but as far as console
favorite console of all time any
generation 360.
i mean i still have like all kinds of
360 going on um yeah 100 oh my gosh
history tremendous journey and absolute
pleasure
[Laughter]
the legendary seth
chazelle and absolute president director
of
executive communications at xbox an
absolute pleasure where can they find
people find you what you got going on
while we lit ya
just uh seth chazelle on twitter i guess
i'm not a huge i don't tweet a lot but
yeah you can find me if you can spell
the name you can find
[Laughter]
the house
absolute presence brother saw if you
want to give up lord set his uh
salutations all the way out yeah i said
uh i gotta just say go red
but uh yes uh absolute pleasure talking
to you i knew it's funny i didn't know
that connection until after our meeting
yesterday i said there's something about
there's a polish to seth that reminds me
of myself of myself
you know what we deal with
and i went to linkedin i was like uh-huh
there you go
i never look polish over these unrefined
lords
we're a special breed
yeah absolutely but no no it's been an
absolute pleasure to have you on your
story and again
until i heard you telling your story you
don't realize
how ingrained into the history of gaming
your career has been just from the very
beginning
it's so interesting and so glad to have
you in the position that you're in
because like we were saying like
microsoft seems to be at the forefront
of wanting to have that connection with
their fans and with their community uh
in a way that the other two of the big
three don't necessarily seem to find as
important in this way and to have
someone like you at the forefront of
that at
the head of that is amazing so again
thank you for your time we really
appreciate it now uh go have some
breakfast thanks all of you really
appreciate it looking forward to
watching the rest of the show no i
appreciate it wait roll down look at
that
king justin
i just want to affectionately call you
the watcher
because you have literally like you said
you were when you did your the
journalistic journey when you went there
for the first time you were there at the
cusp of the 360 and that uh xbox live
boom
right you were there
uh in the beginning you said dot com you
see a lot of people was missing gems
that were hitting
and you were there you were covering
stuff you said stuff like monica
lewinsky a lot of people that went over
a lot of people's heads
definitely went over my head but he's
trying to get his his
his front page he had something that was
front page worthy yeah but something
knocked it out you understand so it's
different struggles here and there
i just actually love
the humbleness i love
your arc you're seeing your view of the
world all the way through to this space
and i only think only you can occupy the
space that you're in now um
because you were uniquely qualified
at every step of the way here like you
said you had different opportunities to
do this or do do that but this
opportunity spoke more to you because
you wanted to be part of a great team
going forward and i do appreciate that
because trust me i really care about the
the microsoft brand as a consumer and to
know that it's people that care about it
and want to see it go in a great
direction that as a consumer that makes
me feel happy and a little bit more
safer with my purchases
thank you
enjoy your sunday and absolute pleasure
the legendary lord set yourself enjoy
your day especially
definitely appreciate you coming on seth
i definitely appreciate it have a good
one brother cheers you talk to your face
thank you no doubt son you want to get
the uh the chats while we are you want
me to do the show
yeah yeah i'm fine because it wasn't it
wasn't too much okay
um
we got a shout out to be lou
i remember for a month i think it came
up like he joined the realm but it says
member for a month so it's the lord's
day shout out to the lords i'm super
proud of y'all fellas and you have a
supporter in me keep killing it and with
time and and with time is the show now
what time is the show now yeah so just a
reminder 11 a.m during football season i
don't know what's going on
phil spencer says he's in the chat i
don't know
who that is but if
if it truly is phil thank you phil thank
you
it's really expensive
i don't know if it is truly him but he
says keep up the great work guys love
this podcast and it's amazing and if it
is him thank you sir it is greatly
appreciated if not see you soon
hopefully you know
we'd love to have you
then we got uh native with the five
dollars of a chat nothing but love to
the crew that's been grinding and
improving every aspect of their lives
you are all incredibly inspirational
happy to see you likewise my brother
kiss will say that's
i think that's the reason like cog even
acknowledged because he wasn't saying
some like off the wall yeah because
normally the fake phil's coming in
they'd be wilding out
what if what if what if it's real phil
with a fake fill account
hey listen i'm done
and we have
sogv with the 10 super chat finally
after tuning in since episode 188 i
can't believe i made it to the realm on
a live showing i'll take my shoes off i
hope king doesn't mind if i set them
next to the knee collection
oh you can put it right there
you can put it by the door man
[Music]
shout out to the home hard get shane
with the 20
the gaming world is dominated by western
and japanese devs what other reasons
would you want to see games from seems
like lots of worlds uh history and
culture is missing from gaming says
answers to this would have been awesome
uh yeah uh
there's something we could definitely
ask seth uh in a later interview but uh
then we have cowboys fans
yeah oh yeah
cowboys fan 404 ten dollars will be chat
when will seth be cast to play obama in
the bible
yeah i said we got we we got obama we
got yeah tigers
i would have went with tiger woods yeah
for sure no doubt what else we got um i
think we're good recorder hold on a
second
good to go yep all right look last week
poll results are in the people have
spoken with the recent
interview and statements by jim ryan
wanted to reach hundreds of millions to
enjoy a playstation game how do you
anticipate sony accomplishing this the
winner of the poll at 56
of the vote was first party playstation
games on pc cloud and mobile group
coming in at second at 32 percent of the
vote was the messy lords i don't care
but i had that same energy when i'm
playing ps5 on a toaster and at last
place it only 10 of the vote was first
party playstation games day and date
sorry king i know that was your choice
but um shout out to all the lords who
participated in the mine was the other
one oh i thought you okay i thought you
were the day of day for them
no you one day today sir i remember you
was going home they're gonna do it
anyway
lord uh thought sir
listen yeah you know listen jim has been
known
to have to you know run back some
statements that have been rushed back
from something
at this point if
you still think that they're not doing
the pc thing
you're just in denial and you don't want
to accept it and like like king said
it's just a matter of time
when the distance between you know the
ps the playstation console release and
the pc release just keeps shrinking
right now i think you might see a year
then eventually you're going to see six
months and then uh go on fourth after
that you'll see three months and then i
would say within a few years it's going
to be day and day i really do i think
honestly jim is world ride gym
he's not jim dan's
worldwide gym
what a wide gym he don't care what you
say he gonna rip the band-aid off
now we're gonna get this work right now
because jim jim needed a yacht so
i did yeah yo yo and i'm gonna tell you
this you're right about that he he look
he's gotten burned a couple of times by
saying things that he knew in the back
of his mind he already knew the cross
true right so
it it would behoove them just to be as
honest as possible he's being more he's
more being more transparent by the game
and look
for the better for it all the better for
it listen guys
you're going to get bigger and better
games because of this they're going to
be everywhere
trust me you don't want to explain
itself worldwide jim don't gotta explain
worldwide jim is the most successful
he understands how to make this money
son so
i think it's gonna put it everywhere and
listen
it doesn't stop you from playing play
for sure for sure oh so if it's day and
day it don't matter if you can get it
down the block go so what you gotta
relax i don't think people
realize like how that corporate stuff
works like
they
it he's been in there enough time he was
there a long time before he even got
that position they didn't just promote
some random dudes like they probably
were someone that was doing good things
it was when your father
saw you in the room and say fix your
inner effective business
that it's making a break you know most
people don't survive that
so yeah yeah you did you know then you
can look at it from the standpoint
that's going on right now that it's like
look like
he's been there for a minute if he
wasn't bringing in results
the fact that
keep in mind this i don't know if it was
him
but
you know cliff when he took over things
started changing and shifting a
different way so i'm assuming he did
have a lot of influence on putting their
stuff to pc right and to
me imagine explaining to sony that you
need stuff on pc like like there has to
be a huge return out the end of that
tunnel for them to continue to yeah yeah
because you know the thing about if you
think about what sean layton why why one
of the reasons sean layton is not there
anymore is like when you his his
thinking was okay in order to maintain
the sony way of doing things
our aaa games have to be smaller
and that's not jim ryan's thinking it's
like they know they have to be bigger as
big as they've always been or bigger
he's about to blockbusters we just have
to we just have to be willing to put it
someplace else and that that's where
they differ and that's where when you
start looking at the bottom line as
as well as sony's first party games have
done just on their platforms
you put those things everywhere
and then
this is where
we start to think about when and why
they're going to start putting them
closer to day and date
i don't care what game it is
games have a zeitgeist moment where
everyone is talking about them yeah and
and it is it is in your best interest to
have it in as many hands as possible
right
if you look at a game like cyberpunk
right cyberpunk
when that game is fully patched next-gen
pass whatever ready to go on console
when it actually comes out right for me
it's just not going to be it's not it's
not going to be
this guy
it's an issue he got that
it just it's not going to be what it
could have been no matter what it's
never going to have that moment again it
will never happen again
and then
we have king now yeah
it is lit i'm not going to be too crazy
with it but you know where do you get
that
we have
peace love life to the lords happy 10k
jen's been doing my homework lately i'm
on episode 12. wow oh wow you're taking
it back today
wow wow yeah yeah i i appreciate you
don't do that
look man go bad like 30 episodes you
don't got to go back 200.
what else we got though there we go
thanks for the great contact king with
the hat to the side needs his own
segment prayers to send us the hashtag
five dollar super chat yachty jim ryan
gonna get mad y'all keep bringing all
these xbox people on the show you ready
for his interview and he now plays yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i got some other stuff here too
oh yeah he got it's crazy when he got
lined up but anyway let's go so look um
about details have leaked shout out to
the amazing jess gordon window central
xbox two with him and some other guy
dual pocket what's that other guy
but there's another person on that
pocket yeah i thought it was jess's
podcast when you look at the articles of
windows central it says
yo brand new i'm playing shout out to
ran out throwing a man with the video
you know what i'm saying but yeah it was
it was out there a lot of leaks a lot of
um information and uh also kind of shout
out to the uh even though it was a leak
shout out to the queen sarah bond for
mistakenly retweeting it and then
retracting the retweet
oh yeah this probably wasn't supposed to
be out just yet but that's how good
was that
i'm kind of curious that that was like
like
sheila she realized that she made a
mistake or like pr's like yo
cause the impulse was to tweet and then
the pullbacks i'm like yeah somebody
probably gotta hold up but look let's
just get a couple of details for them
from this uh big article on about it's
uh jess wrote the otterworld fans
already have plenty of reasons to be
excited about obsidian's upcoming slate
given that auto worlds 2 has been
confirmed a vow seems to be based on a
similar albeit enhanced engine from
other worlds complete with action
oriented first-party first-person combat
and deep rpg exploration and narrative
systems he said he told a vow will
feature multiple class play styles
borrow from skyrim's two-handed combat
systems you could wield two daggers it'd
be a stealthy road dive into archery
with a two-handed bowl you could use a
combination of sword and magic or go
full two-handed magic which is required
to will some of the game's most potent
spells and abilities so it's gonna be in
that pillar of eternity's world wizard
spell they talk about two-handed spells
that you could do the fireball the
conjuring complex looking hand gestures
decimate enemies with magma and fire
she's seen status effect spells all type
of stuff weapon enhancement it does
sound very impressive so based on the
leaks let's get it over to you lord
addict this is all bad we kind of like
these type of games you know where you
at with these leaks man how excited are
you about it
i'm excited for it now he didn't mention
that
the outer worlds will be on the same
engine i'm pretty sure it's uh unreal
engine 4.
um so i'm hoping that maybe they i don't
know valve's been such a development
that's probably going to be on four
like i'm not saying
that
the engine is an issue because it's not
i'm just saying that you know
i would prefer
something like the unreal engine 5 or
something like that but i do understand
that this is this is really foreign
development you even even know that they
said pre-development i don't think
people understand what that term means
he actually made a correction to it
though he was kind of saying
it's not he's actually said he made a
mistake in article not as what was the
word was it pre-production or whatever
that it may be out of that until the
alpha because on xbox two just recently
last night he actually said he wish he
didn't say that so the vibe again this
is just speculation according to him and
according to grub
is maybe
late 2023 is what we hear
so that that's updated
i do think this game is going to come
out 2023. i don't think people realize
like fully have a concept of how much
the pandemic has pushed the whole
industry back like i i think people feel
like there's a only couple studios like
i no
there wasn't like
i'm willing to bet you your average game
in the industry got pushed back at least
six months
so and that's at least like look avowed
i i do you know he kind of hinted on
there that you know he doesn't know if
it's going to be uh hub world or right
or you know
oh open world no he did say there's some
job listings suggest it's open world so
i'm gonna i'm assume it's it's hub or
open i they did do obsidian which is hub
world like i i would prefer hub world
because i feel like you can actually
build a good narrative with the world
but i wouldn't care if they did an open
world either uh i i know i i understand
people feel like everything has to be
overall in terms of that type of style
yeah but like look at the end of the day
let's be real here you take the whole
map of skyrim
sure you could travel to other areas but
once you may come across that area one
time your ass is fast traveling
that you know that's why i feel like hub
world's fine like narrative i feel like
is important now if they do go hub world
and they're able to really navigate on
on you know character development on
your cam companions character
development on the actual places because
when it's hub world you can actually
have a lot more in terms of development
on uh you know terms of the game at a
point of the game it's because if when
it's open it's a lot harder to do stuff
like that but when it's hub world you
can have giant wars and stuff going on
and where you know certain parts of the
maps destroyed because you have that
certain aspect like megaton in fallout 3
because you walked into that place
that's when you saw that giant thing get
destroyed so you know i don't really
care what they do uh because i have a
lot of faith in obsidian in general
and i think that you know
they're going to be able to do
anything they want in any type of realm
i would prefer hub world but i
understand why they would do it yeah
if they did want to um
i like the the hand gestures
a lot of people don't know well there's
a lot of people but for people who don't
know
about is taking place in the pillars of
eternity world
and
i i i recommend all of you go to
youtube and look up
the lore of pillars of eternity because
that stuff is in detail just as in
detail to something like skyrim they got
fake gods like it's it's it's crazy how
that game interacts i love how they're
you know really capitalizing they're
they're making the pillars of eternity
universe and they're bringing it to life
right where you know uh because
i was looking at the the opening trailer
apparently a lot of people in that
community the pillars of turning the
community think that this is going to be
a prequel
to the pillars of eternity franchise
because a lot of people don't know this
pillars of eternity is pretty much a
god's been dethroned and you're helping
uh you're you're neither hurting or
helping that god and a lot of people
think that uh because the god's already
been dethroned by pillars of eternity
one people think that this is during
that time you might be the antagonist
that actually dethrones that god right
so you know that's what people think it
i look look at the end of the day
avowed i think to come out there and hit
i really do yeah i think the outer
worlds 2 is going to come out there and
hit i i think if you want to compare any
studio that sony has to any student that
microsoft has in terms of
consistency i think this is their
installment
it's like you read my damn my internal
notes that was good but it was my verb
yo that's crazy i was about to say that
that's so crazy you said that it's it's
it's their insomniac now look
i don't know exactly what uh in terms of
quality clearly we saw outer worlds too
yeah that was a great game highly
reviewed sold well and that was on a
budget and i'm not saying they're like
unlimited budget but i'm saying obsidian
has enough clout in microsoft and has
enough plot that they went out and
bought microsoft that
i can almost guarantee this this studio
is heavily funded yeah so you know it's
nice to see that you know we see the
ninja theories you know uh he even said
on there that he's hearing a lot of good
stuff about how blade three two so it's
nice to see these studios getting what
they're getting i he did bring up that
you know there's a lot of aspects in
terms of the element weapons and you
know that's the biggest thing i want
involved i want to be able to play the
way i want to play and i want magic
being accessible
and being a play style itself like i
don't like games that have different
play styles but when it comes to the
magic you really have to be just
straight up mage to have an effective
use of magic like right i like what he
brought up ice arrows that means you can
be a ranged character and you can have
magic to enhance that ranged play style
and that's what i like i like stuff like
that and i'm really enjoying the fact
that they're really enhancing that
gameplay it's like look
i love the fact that microsoft owns
bethesda software studios and obsidian
because you're going to low key see
competition going on within within the
joint yes
so you know you're going to see probably
about in 2023
and then you're going to see elder
scrolls six and probably 20 20 at the
end of 2024 at the end of 2025. so i
like that they're constantly going to be
pushing each other forward because you
see that with a and sony you see them
constantly competing with each other yo
you got god of war here's last of us too
what's that ragnarok looking like
and i like that that
inner studio competition that's going to
push the entire franchise forward
someone did bring up exile exile as well
uh you know our guest seth brought up um
uh interval oh no not interpol
[Laughter]
a lot of the people don't know but that
studio when they separated created
obsidian created a about like um exile
entertainment like and what's crazy is
microsoft has like the the pieces to
like thanos's gauntlets in their studios
the whole meme with phil going around
throwing them in there yeah
he did it let's get solving so man what
you feeling obviously jazz articles got
everybody bubbling how we feeling about
evolve
i'm super excited about about and
specifically to the last point that
attic made going back to what seth was
talking about with interplay when you
talk about those interplay games you
talk about playing scape tournament you
talk about halter's gate you talk about
ice windale all of that stuff that has
roots in dungeons and dragons
so
baldur's gate is interesting because
when that game came out
people were like nah i don't think
they're gonna be able to do what
dungeons and dragons does in the game
and they and they did it
they did it in a way that like when you
when you're faced with any situation in
that game
there's a hundred different ways you can
tackle it
and
there's a level of detail and
manipulation there that like a lot of
rpgs just don't have right and but
that's the sort of starter going with
that route with that you know with their
with their with oblivion and with
morrowind and stuff like that but still
not to that degree so when you tell me
you're making a game that looks like
skyrim and oblivion and has those sort
of sensibilities but at the same time
your roots are pillars of eternity which
is the spiritual successor to things
like baldur's gate
it's super exciting to me because at
that point now
i'm looking at a first person rpg that
has all of those
small little details that you can
manipulate in those old games
the way no games have done to date like
that's why you see yeah people who are
really big into those games so excited
for bowser's gate three because no other
game has really done that yeah that is
the immersive sim of rpg you know who
goes hard for that shout out i got a
shout out to our assistant editor
oh yeah nick nick
nick goes hard for that game for that
reason continue it it is so
for me when you look at the outer worlds
the outer worlds is that perfect sort of
mixture of fallout with with brighter
colors and things like that the things
that people would have wanted from
fallout and and i think about is the
same thing where rao feels like it's
gonna it's gonna give you all of those
things that you kind of expect from a
skyrim and i i don't think it's going to
be as dark as it is as that he's kind of
yeah he said yeah i just
i just want to point out that it's very
important that obsidian
makes their versions of these games of
the skyrims of the elder scrolls i mean
that's the same thing but yeah the
fallouts but what i like what they
because originally when i saw obsidian's
outer worlds uh first thing i thought
was man they're just making another
fallout and that's disappointing but
when you play the outer worlds you
realize this is not a fallout game it's
not something unique it's not the same
thing it looks like it but it it not at
all and i think about it's going to be
that i think despite how that initial
trailer looked like it was very dark i
think overall it's going to have a
lighter tone because if you look at pool
of eternity the tone for certain things
is lighter there are deep
and interesting and sort of heavy
stories in there but the overall tone
isn't as bleak as something so uh to me
it's going to be a mixture of all that
but what excites me most is
the possibility of getting that type of
game play in this type of looking game
yes right yes because a balder's gate
you go back to it now unless you love
that
you're going to look at it and it's the
same
it's the same thing about that third
person over the shoulder when you see
that it's exciting because it's pretty
it's graphically appealing right
you need to give me if you give me that
game play in a package that's wide
widely appealing yeah
it's gonna hit i think about it's gonna
hit if they hit all those notes and they
get it right
i'm very excited for a while i'm super
excited king where you at man with these
leaks about how you feeling 2023 who the
hell cares
who the hell cares i can't wait for them
to wave your fingers and you're able to
slice and dice
i got a whole year of other stuff but
you stop talking about stuff that might
come out yeah let's just not talk let's
just not talk about it yeah let's just
do it let's just not talk about it
how dare us be excited about something
they make how dare us
you're getting excited about wolverine
in 2025.
you know what i'm not
like like i keep that same energy like
and he's right here wolverine is right
here you know what he's just worrying
about a wolverine game that gave you cgi
i don't care
exactly
king guess what though at the end of the
day are you on a podcast are you not on
them
we can talk about sports and combat you
know what it is
[Applause]
yo but you know what don't talk about it
don't talk about the future champion and
not like that cause we gotta talk about
what's going on
you know why this is this is this is
actually putting a crow a crux in his
claw because
he cares about this game so much yeah
like he really do like this is hit he's
like it's gonna be crazy it's obsidian
it's nuts it's a valve it's crazy and
i'm like
let's get to the part where they're
actually showing some games they showed
the gameplay he saw it
that i actually sit here and play the
games that come out and i'm i'm scared
i'm smart with all this game pass stuff
we're jumping in and playing all these
games i don't care about the game that
ain't coming out
i don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow so if the world blocked the
ball a vibe never came out but guess
what i was playing i'm playing
huffington
this guy is something else man i
actually no
okay
it's coming from a studio that i do like
i do like the past work and the stuff
sounds promising but you know in all
seriousness the stuff sounds promising i
do i want something like a skyrim do i
want something like a king's fall do i
want something that's expansive i don't
want a hub world actually i want you to
be able to walk around the world you
know in the free roaming aspect of the
world so i don't want anything that's
like controlled because anytime you have
like a hub situation it feels like
you're controlled like you have to keep
coming back to this place i want you to
be freedom i thought that was what made
skyrim fantastic and great that it was
an open situation and you go to
different towns and you can go into
those different towns and different
stuff happen organically from that
aspect whereas
if attic plays it he can play it in a
different way that i would play it yet a
story is structured in the manner that
we will get to those same paths together
but he can do something totally
different so that's what i'm looking for
i don't want a hub world not at all
this is a good one man um shout out to
again the description was crazy you know
the fact that he's
seen gameplay shout out to red i guess
red sword as well you know whatever this
thing where they saw all the stuff
pretty much the the blueprint from
microsoft
moving forward with all these studios
that they saw but um yeah with this
joint i'm just i got to be with my man
addict doing i'm i'm i'm stupid hype man
like it's just it's the pillars of
eternity world it's their take you know
i like that obsidian they were in their
bag you know
pre-acquisition and stuff like that
and i'm i'm different from you king and
i in the sense i do like hub world over
i'm tired of the world i'm gonna be real
i'm tired overall i'm just i'm tired of
a hundred icons on the screen i'm tired
of the fake
illusion oh gosh
i'm so sick of that like there's so many
games that do that like it's like if you
want to do that do fry cry do red dead
do all that i want to contain story
like how out of worlds is where i can
it's more choices affected i feel like
in numb games
huh i play
i know i'm not saying you didn't
i know i like the fact that a hub world
sort of condenses things and makes it
easier to sort of parse out instead of
like you said like sometimes you see all
those icons on screen and it gets
intimidating and you don't want to do
anything yeah i wonder
right so the thing about it is one i
don't want that though
yeah one of the things that i hope for
right one of the things that i hope for
going into this generation was okay what
if we don't necessarily have super
expansive open world right
but they're more condensed and denser
right if
it is yes right if it is i just don't
want this fake you can play a hundred
hours
look at this this fake filler to just
extend it tell me a better story i
wanted the tightest i wanted to feel
like skyrim
okay i mean but today i got skyrim for
that like to be skyrim is in the same
house
but they're going to make the new sky
room but then we go again so i'ma have
two skyrims
yeah i think i think i think the the
most the modern rpg that sort of
exemplifies that and it's crazy because
it's still a humongous rpg is the
witcher 3 because the witcher 3
it's it's a huge game
but yeah
about the combat
that gets the worst ever
everything every side story there
matters some of them even double back
onto the main story in a way that yeah i
i know what you're talking about with
filler it's just like go fetch this go
get this go get that and it gets tired
it gets tired i'm just tired
it's too many of them games that they
are elder scrolls is in the building we
know it's coming because this here
let this be what it's going to be
i want to
what it organically turns itself into
because i know they're going to separate
themselves pretty much from everything
that's there being that this is the game
that everybody's leaning heavily on it
you know to be honest with you like i
hear the conversation i hear attic
leaning heavily into it i hear jazz
leaning heavily into it everybody's
excited about this game and they lean
heavily into it look if it is i'm still
going to play it you know i'm saying i'm
still going rock it's obsidian at the
end of the day but the thing like i said
the the different archetypes i like all
that short you know sword and shield you
know two-headed magic well-handed magic
you know what i say two-handed fire in
one hand
yeah you know what i'm saying like those
are the tropes that you know that i
really love and then he said swimming is
in the game
so unlike remember out of the world
wasn't doing none of that and to your
point would solve what i like is you got
your dark areas you got your dungeon but
then the thing that they're doing is
that very color palette where you got
the bright areas the the flush the flora
and all that other stuff but yo we got
we're gonna have to put i'm with attic
man we're gonna have to put respect on
obsidian name like they my number one
draft pick bro like look look already
you got a vowel
they're making out of worlds two
we still don't even talk about what josh
sawyer's game is remember josh sawyer
got a game an obsidian in tuck
and you know i had to bend the knee
already to ground it i'm already playing
i'm in the new inside of beta joint
i ain't gonna front king the things
they've changed and how the engine look
now
i'm clowned again i clowned the hell out
of that yeah i clowned i was so mad when
i heard her and then i was like
it's kind of fun like i go i get it i
get it i get it so salute to them now
here's the thing just dropped the
bombshell yesterday solved it y'all know
if y'all heard this
he was like um
obsidian plans to release
a game
for xbox
every year for the next seven
years let's go
bro that's crazy do you know how in tuck
you are with your development like they
was already correct so i'm with attic
that's ins that i passed insomniac yeah
like you're doing a game every year for
the next seven years
bro
get it at it go i love i love that
they're doing that but
i do want them to cool down a little bit
on that kind of talk
like i i don't i don't
know it's just like my my concern is you
keep spreading yourself then the games
are like i'm not going to say the
quality is going to drop but if you in
order to do that you have to have a
bunch like a bunch of teams in the
studio
i've always been the kind of well i've
always been that kind of person that i'm
like two two teams man like because it's
just like
when you keep splitting up like 150
people they've proven they could do it
they just gave them out of worlds yeah
if they if they hit them if they hit
they could whatever i don't care if they
if they see you know if they hit it it's
fine it's just me
and myself i'm just concerned if you
keep splitting the teams up over and
over again
they're working on newer stuff like
splitting my team saying hey they've
already got the team split and they
hiring more people this is not them
compromising what they're doing to say
hey break this up in the section so we
can partner their whole new job
yeah josh sawyer just said that his team
is like 15 20 yeah this is a smaller
team
i guess my concern is just like
i would i i'm just nervous on you know
continuously like that like getting
another bleeding edge i love that gang
but it's just like you know the that's
digital you don't want that put this no
that's ninja theory sir that's that's it
to me
to me it's just like you know if you
split up the studio and keep making more
and more teams i'm just worried that you
know the quality of the story
we got to stop now
i just think maybe i i just think the
expectation we need to have
is that amongst those are going to be
smaller experiences there's going to be
another grounded sized experience
i think they they they got this little
wave right and i think they just build
the frame of the house and pass it on to
the next dude to finish it up and then
come in and check stuff out i think they
own some old uh
like um
what what what what's what is the
quadruple a studio initiative oh the
initiative i got initiatives
listen listen what i'm saying like they
have their teams
build it up
and all right these teams is working on
that so we cranking out this we already
got the framework for this let's get in
there put in the sheetrock let's put the
ceiling in
let's get the wiring done let's get this
done all right let's go back to it let's
check it out that's the only way you can
do a game a year is if you already have
that's the team building out the
framework of said game with the
parameters and then everybody else
jumping on board to finish said game up
right that that's why i'm just concerned
with it because like a game a year guys
like
well well the thing is all right
that way
right but you guys
are acting like like like the
development is a year long dude these
games have probably been in development
and then they're looking at their
release cadence and they're like well we
can we can hit a release per year for
the next seven years because we've
started these games way back way back
when before the microsoft acquisition
that's right this is during the private
division days let's be real we acted
like they came to microsoft so all right
guys we're gonna do seven
no start from scratch from scratch let's
build about come on it ain't that this
is no microwave situation
they've been in a bag before it just so
happened microsoft came and now it's
like oh okay we got this too okay cool
they was moving already
[Applause]
it's like what are they making a game
for
four i mean i guess we can go around the
two otter worlds josh saw his game
grounded four teams i mean are they
going to stop
supporting grounded and just make
something new like that
that's that's my thing it's just like if
that team makes something new like they
have to make something new so they said
they make a game every year like like
that maybe they're just talking about
the next couple years because stuff has
turned out to be the way it is but like
like i guess i i think technically
grounded comes out next year doesn't it
yeah grounded
cause i think it's still in the beta and
that's just my only concern it's like
i just want quality gains from them and
i'm just concerned if you know you have
that many teams of a studio making
something
something happen
[Music]
don't be putting that on my studio i
don't like that on my screen
look i have this down all jokes inside i
understand your concern and it's valid
i'm not i'm not i shouldn't minimize it
because it is valid we want to make sure
the quality is maintained and i get that
i get it just i was surprised when jess
said that that to me they had to me that
means i look at it you look at it as
concern which is valid i look at it as
they got mad stuff cooking up that
they've been ready to put out and get
into motion that's all i look at but
we'll see what happens it's just like
there's like 180 or 200 people working
there like you keep splitting that that
amount of group up between four teams
like
i just i i just get concerned because
it's just like you always be
conservative in this studio you like i
already know how you do you all right
well i mean
that's the time you should be concerned
i get it until the quality go down out
of worlds was hit and ain't nobody was
concerned about the quality and this is
all during the seven games a year joint
but i feel you i mean if you would be
concerned you could be concerned it's
cool but um look that's what it is um
let's get this move on because we still
got a lot of joints to get through so
i'm really super chat we're gonna move
yeah give me a second we have
gammonomics with the hundred i don't
know where this is from i i'm gonna say
100 oh no rubies we found rupees okay
thank you thank you gaminomics from
india 100 100 rupees uh bow to the lords
i was kind of hoping to see phil spencer
at dc fandom and announced the wwp games
acquisition just wishful thinking
xbox is missing is bioware and cd
projekt red and they'll have all
infinity stones for western rpgs yeah
they
definitely have it unlocked
i got to disagree with that like i feel
like
cyberpunk hurt cd projekt red a lot feel
like that the people that make divinity
that's who they need like
because divinity's quality you know what
i'm saying that's the biggest thing i
just i don't want s i don't want
oh what's what i'm looking for what
would you really uh uh inspirations and
i don't want like trying to trying to go
above and beyond like
lower the quality of games that's all
like no i get it because like when it
comes to divinity like i love that game
and uh bioware if i were i'm not gonna
say
bioware is just one of those studios
that they need to prove themselves but a
for before i feel like they're worthy of
being in the name of people like
obsidian people of course like uh you
know but that's the song that you're
doing because
yeah regardless fallout 76 hurt the
fallout brand and the bethesda name
but there's a software didn't make that
game so i don't think that comes off on
them no doubt no doubt what else you
guys saw
kenny k five dollar super chat do you
think xbox game studios will share game
engines i id tech slip space creation
engine etc yes yes yes
yeah
and we have splendiferous with the two
dollar super chat
god get off the fence you love it but
are tired of the icons
yeah i mean it's just just me that's
where i disagree i just you know i'm
just sick of that you know 100 you know
as you get older you can't have time to
be able to invest in 100 hour games
either get it go in the wilderness and
do it just give me the damn story let's
get a good shot in the world
kill the narrative
let's get me to give me the kill i want
to kill the immersion 200 hours it's
just the vr guys the vr guy says
bloat that's all it is just tell a good
story
that's why mass effect is fired because
they told a good story go to every
planet
no
tell a good damn story get off my lawn
get out there
fake expert fake things that you could
just put on a box you can do 200 things
no tell a good start
i'm sorry i'm just almost there
[Laughter]
anyway look so this is you dc fandom
what's that man
yeah man we had a dc fandom 2021
yesterday
and just to just generally speaking
i gotta tell you man i love this format
for all things dc it is like it is it is
a love letter to fans of all things dc
that i think uh marvel just needs to
copy
be successful with what they do but i
tell you this losing fix they face and
do it right but this is the thing right
and i'm not going to talk about the
movie thing i think marvel at this point
i can't wait marvel at this point is not
nearly i mean we have we obviously we
have disney plus right and we've had
that that improvement on the tv side of
things but dc for a long time has been
on the tv front the animated front doing
their thing it's been the movies right
that hasn't haven't really hit yeah and
now
so
for me
it's just the fact that this puts as
much love and emphasis on like the
comics and stuff like that in a way that
marvel doesn't do right so for all
things dc this is a love letter to the
fans so awesome um
yeah it was it was awesome it could be
there were some parts that you see this
all the same for me as much but the fact
that they put that much love and effort
into it uh specifically the fact that
they were they were putting a lot of
people of color actors of color shows
with actors of color at the forefront
kind of at it was was very cool to see
um but just so just to speak generally
about the cool stuff we saw then we'll
get into the gaming specific stuff yeah
um
which i think of the batman the trailer
what y'all think of that trailer for the
batman scout fight
i'm frozen
i'm about twilight twilight batman let's
go twilight batman i honestly think
this has the potential i know it's
blasphemous
but it has the potential to be the best
batman movie ever made that hallway
scene yeah where that dude is lighting
them up with that tommy gun gun and he's
just walking oh yeah
yo because it's it's little things that
we don't ever get a chance to see like
okay so you can't do that with uh old
old-school batman from the tv show you
can't right
you know he gets shot boom oh my
shoulder
boom crash
so and we we've all seen the other
batman's you know one batman got shot
got shot in the head he's like oh one
shot you don't have to take one bullet
but this one man they was unloading on
him and he has a level of brutality
yes
batman he told him i don't care
and the thing is because you know he's a
smaller batman it kind of it hits even
harder because he's like this is a small
dude he's just angry as hell breaking
news uh
xbox game publishing
just tweeted i was gonna say that
earlier we we're excited to kick some
off something special tomorrow just give
us one more day to prepare the chickens
xbox game studios publishing twitter
account
just chickens we did that i don't know
what the chickens and different
paris it's fable paris retweeted
wandering dutch people putting fable
people putting fable it's stuff
they bought they bought pub g like what
do you what is it that like you know
we're gonna win the chicken dinner let's
get it what's the chicken
i think it's fable bro i think it's
fable
they're excited to kick something off
something special tomorrow just give us
one more day to prepare the chicken
[Laughter]
but then they got another tweet we'd
call it our fable anniversary but that
name was already taken they literally
you know fabled
interesting sorry to interrupt yourself
but i had to talk about i was like
i was like what is this chicken kicking
let's kick them chickens what's going on
okay maybe your favorite trailer
collaboration with kfc gaming imagine
that
maybe
maybe maybe
i'm really starting to think that yeah
that's that's what's going to be there
they're enhanced or yeah or maybe a
rematch
no i doubt that because the way the way
they the way no because i don't think
they're gonna show game play on a random
what's tomorrow what if they're monday
maybe they'll just be like
then i will bend the knee next week too
like damn i want the knees i don't want
the knees i don't want the knees for
that i want all the good stuff there's a
reason
the reason that i think that that it's
not like it's something to do with the
original ones it says we would call it
our fable anniversary but the game was
already taken so they're kind of already
like look this is something in the past
not something in the future okay
interesting you'll be vision x enhanced
s enhanced so you honestly think it's
facebook it's something everybody yeah
they're talking about chickens no no no
i i think it's something fable but i
don't think it's something with the new
fable i think it's no i think it's the
old fable yeah old fable something super
x enhanced 120 but don't the old fable
exist or what could they do with old
friends yeah
well it's like it's like i said you know
there's a couple without though
resolution thing what they could be
doing is maybe
maybe they've been making like remaking
fable one in the background no one knows
and they can announce that like yeah be
crazy
and they get rid of that stupid
cinematic stuff because if you notice
if you notice
game uh studio publishing the people
that deal with other studios working
with microsoft like they pop they they
tweeted that my xbox didn't tweet that
like the game studio publishing that's
the arm that gives you stuff like yeah
uh so they so maybe they've contracted
someone to remake to redo it yeah
to me if it's a remake or something like
that like not a remake like an upgrade
on like the frame rates or something
like that i think xbox would be tweeting
it it's ironic that a gunshot
i feel like it's it's something bigger
than that just because
xbox game studios is tweeting that not
xbox that's a good point that's a good
point yeah i'm sorry sorry back to tcp
no no no man i'm excited for this i want
to see fable okay that's let's see let's
see
i know what my video is tomorrow
real quick my topic next week
he's claiming it now shout out to paul
he said weekly news about studios
leading up to the xbox editor that would
be crazy yeah it'd be crazy they'd come
out and they'd be like and pogba the
remix is coming out part two thank you
one bad mother said that it's their
publisher norm so that can signify a
partnership to him interesting yes xbox
game
interesting
someone said the 20th anniversary when
is that anyway continues off
uh yeah real quick be lou two dollar
super chat xbox collabing with the hound
to eat all the chickens
savage savage
so yeah uh back to fandom yeah batman is
looking absolutely bonkers uh i really i
really do think it's it's gonna be a
special one hopefully um we got shazam
we got the second aquaman movie we got
we got black adam looking crazy tell me
what you thought when you saw
that flash that i think the flash
trailer got me so hyped i jumped off the
couch and it was like yes yeah we we had
our issues with ezra miller as the flash
fixed it
and it fixed it and he's i'm just about
i've accepted he's a different flat yeah
that's fine yeah um but again they got
the other flash there exactly exactly
what's this with the going back to the
michael keaton
i've been hard on that i've been hard on
that flash but yeah this that was fun
ever since he did do what he did
i mean everything so that's what you did
yeah we know what he did and even the
smaller stuff like you look at the like
the the batgirl movie this coming blue
beetle movie that's coming
yeah the cartoon stuff they always lit
with that
that woman hunted yeah
all of that
more more what's it called the what's it
called the cape crusader the animated
show yes um there's just so much is not
even what was it the teen titans
[Music]
oh no no
minutes ago but when i saw who tweeted
it i just assumed it was something else
that was a fake that wasn't fable
related i didn't think it was it was
easy i'm just teasing yeah so i mean
again all things dc they're really
hitting on all aspects of it if you if
you don't care about the big characters
you're gonna find something hit a lot so
let's get into the game stuff right
first off rock steady suicide squad
killed the justice league 120 frames per
second boy that thing looked good
wait hold on hold on no no no no no
fraud alert okay
is this the same man
i don't want to see cinnamon cinematic
trailers
i don't want to see the cinematics you
see ggi's
in the game
so now it's good now it's good because
in game with no gameplay
it was that it was good it was the
second showing it was the second showing
you know what i mean
i just wonder if it's good now this was
that was a cgi though what was it that
was in game that was in game engine
right right with a game play what you
saw
polygons
gamepl
i'm good oh you go oh so now oh that's
the caveat so that's what they say is
even though starfield said that and you
said no star feel crap that ain't this
even though they said that was in engine
you was going home
i was happy with that first thing but it
was so far out oh you know what i'm
going to talk about what is what you
like
come out like next year
all right so you're talking about games
that that's like five six years out
and they was talking about games before
like just just the vows is supposed to
come out the year after next stop it
like stop it
but you know what it is i love it how
all of us are fine
all of it is frauds with instead it was
except what it's awesome
kids about stuff
all of us are frauds it's when we love
what we love you don't matter
suicide squad i said yo first i'm
looking forward to finding you guys i
said oh my god this looks good hell yeah
and then i was looking at the draw
distance when he was driving down
man bro
it looks it looks amazing
between them
why they was doing that to the big
winners
i wasn't feeling that i like the fact
that made him smart again um
my only worry still is that remember
there was this thinking that it was some
sort of service based game yeah and i
really hope it ain't that because just
to see i just want to give me a 20 hour
story
story with them yeah the story is
brainiac is hijacking the um the justice
league
they are called in
to to actually take them down take out
take them down and that's not gonna be
easy at all
wow
though what's up
i'm gonna have to be honest with you
guys that's like i gotta be in game pass
for me to play oh dead really
really don't care okay
you never liked the whole battle
never like the old alchemist i like them
but like
i just i i don't know for some reason
the plot in this i'm just not down like
maybe i got to see gameplay to actually
like really resonate with it but it's
just like the plot of this i'm just like
seems like a lot of people or if you
weren't
it is about to happen and he's talking
about a vow two three
but no no
[Music]
i
i haven't seen nothing that happened at
this calm thing i don't know what they
showed in oh so you're really
[Laughter]
too i played
the champion
attic we all frauds all every last one
of us because you frauded because it me
and you fraud it will enjoy two three
out of three frauds
so we have okay so we have that the
suicide squad that i think
it seems like it kind of calms some
people's fears about what that game was
hopefully i'm not wrong and it is not i
am wrong i i don't want it to be some
sort of service based game please don't
do that um then we got gotham knights
the court of owls
so gotham knights looks a little more
stylized right this is w montreal the
art style looks a little bit more
stylized
yeah
stuff yes yes it does look it does look
like a cross-gem game
it's supposed to be right i'm gonna be
real with
way before whatever the hell this is
because the first one they showed the
fight and it was like the game plan is
fighting mr freeze and then this one are
you trying to give me the story was it
the owl quarter wow
this is one of those trailers that if i
see as an ad before a youtube video i'm
just waiting for the skip button
well what worries me about this one a
little bit is that when you you think
about the court of owls right that that
should be a very bruce wayne
batman-centric story and obviously
it's not right it's it's not batman
supposedly dead in this game right which
of course he's going to come back at
some point right but i i'm interested to
see what they do with that because when
you think about the quarterbacks and
their enforcers and what they represent
what is about what it's about what how
about why they're so important like i
mean i don't know i'm afraid with them
quarterbacks is basically made up of the
most powerful influential people in all
of gotham they sort of they they know
they're illuminati they like right
right and there is there is a tie to
obviously bruce's family with that but
in this game he's supposed to be dead
right he's not going to be dead right
okay exactly so it's the bat family
fighting got you um but the the the
talon and talons and the kind of the
enforcers for the quarterback they're
very very skilled fighters so in terms
of the combat and stuff like that we
expect from these games i think it'll be
on point it's just a matter of the hit
with the story right and everything else
and being able to incorporate it with
four different player characters right
and it's the co-op destiny style joint
right this like some mmo a little bit
it's two-player right and yeah you do
get like upgrades and stuff like that xp
and upgrades and stuff like that you get
combo moves and things of that nature i
think you can play single player as well
um remember we saw the gameplay of this
yeah
like for the first time yeah
it looks fun it's just like to me it got
to be in that 99
give me give me a second i just throw
water all over my electronics no
oh no
oh
it was uh
my what you would call it my uh my
surgery
oh okay you could just blow it up okay
bro shut down if you got to
yo somebody say get the race i'm done
anyway let's try it out
as bad as i've felt here recently man
like i want to put my whole ass body in
to think of rice at this point
but could take you i want your opinion
on this before you move on because um
like you you this is you you you the
lord dude you did you know you know
what's going on are they keeping it true
to these games like where are you at
yo i'm not gonna lie dc fandom did so
much fan service like saab was saying
oh it's it's they have so much to give
like usually when we get these cons a
lot of people will do it wrong
dc actually has been doing it right ever
since this whole pandemic it's like they
were prepared for this whole situation
and what i've what i've noticed like
with their games with their movies with
their cartoons and with their tv shows
they're leaning heavily into the
material yes like they're trying to keep
it as comic book accurate as possible
uh for the fans
marvel has a whole separate universe the
mcu is a completely different universe
than what is uh the marvel universe you
know the 616 uh in these type of worlds
so
when when you see this stuff
the fact that they're going to do
the the the flash story
that story is deep
right and that story has to deal with
his mother dying but then you see the tv
show flash
there
so this is what everybody's been
clamoring about if you didn't like the
ezra uh flash
but then you got the guntensen flash
i think they're going to do a fan
service and you get a chance to see him
and on the big screen so the gunther one
is in there he he it looks like it
appears like okay yeah i don't know like
turn around be a whole toe i got you but
they seem to be maybe eluding yeah but
they never show the face okay okay they
never show the face so
um
you you see i have a freud lower
question because i don't know anything
about black adam when you finish
okay oh okay well we can jump from that
to get to exactly this long film that's
been uh in production that is coming out
the film that is probably actually the
one that's done the most um and ready to
go is the black adam film with the rock
that he's been talking about for the
last seven years
educate me because i know nothing
so what is he in relationship to shazam
he was the first oh he the first dude
lightning bolt he was in the feral times
you know yeah so his his i thought he
was like a villain no
he's the one that was sort of
unworthy or whatever but no yeah
yeah all right so okay
back back
he
right so
he was back then in ancient egypt times
and stuff like that
the the justice society is who he's
going to fight right so he's going to
fight adam and yeah adam smasher he's
going to smash her doctor dr fate is my
yo you saw who they got playing yeah
man the way you guys are talking man
these names
sound like something off like a b rating
i don't know what's going on i'm a fraud
the naming the naming conventions in dc
are not uh
so but to see that black adam is going
to go up against the justice society now
what they did was they froze him away in
time they got a chance a way to stop him
because he was ruling with all these
powers back then now he was frozen for a
period of time and they weren't
archaeology
finding
something they didn't know what they
were finding and they found him they
spoke his name when he was locked in a
certain tomb and then his lightning came
down he got released so he's going to
probably be released in probably a
decade or two later from his original
time and trying to bring back his uh his
city back to prominence
now he's an anti-hero because his views
and ideology is different from ours
right
at this he's still it's like if captain
america
i'm not going to say like a racist but
if captain america was um like us
no had like not let's say captain
america was a nazi right okay and
whatever his ideology was and is when he
got frozen
he came out with that
right and he's trying to push that
agenda forward but with the powers of
like superman right okay all right so
he's an anti-hero and he's learning but
can't call the world last question i
know i'm holding it all up but i gotta
ask like he he the magic dude right so
he because the magic dude is going to be
super man can't shazam beat superman
because because superman can't believe
that's why i love suzanne yeah he can't
be magic so so is shazam never have to
deal with black adam okay so in the end
of this the the the shazam movie when
they're all sitting down on thrones yeah
and they go yo it's a separate hey
there's a seat missing like who who's
this for yeah
he's part of that hierarchy oh like the
gods are gone but his gods are different
gods okay so he gets his powers from
different people got you okay right and
zam got his power it's like a generation
i actually like the shazam
yeah that's what i said
i actually like a lot of the the um the
dc the dc movies that people don't like
like i liked uh uh superman versus
batman like
like because i i'm not like a comic book
person so
like i don't notice i don't notice when
they be messing stuff up
[Laughter]
yeah like you know when when they
because i didn't know that like you know
wonder woman's sword couldn't cut
doomsday like that and i see people
bitching about it i'm just like yo i
thought it looked cool
[Laughter]
but technically it kind of makes sense
because the sword is magic gotcha and
the fact that you know he's kryptonian
and magic right i'll just make my
comments because my i don't know nothing
so i'm just going to talk um suicide
trailer was fire i'm all in
everything they were doing the tone the
humor i love the scenario it seems
impossible this ragtag group that got to
deal with all this wildness they nailed
the feel of the game i think i got an
idea of it looks great gotham nice like
i said you know again i didn't i guess i
didn't know i guess y'all open because
y'all know this court of owls and all
this so i'm just like alright what the
hell is this what we doing right but i
will say you know it fleshed it out i
like seeing nightwing up at the joint
and um i just want to know more more
gameplay stuff as they're going with
that and they can keep that dc pet game
i
unapologetic yeah yeah unapologetically
they're about like every every corner of
the dc universe they're gonna get no and
shout out to them
because they finally look like they
fleshing out their universe like they
finally look like yo dc universe movies
is looking like they popping you got the
black adam aquaman 2 flashlights
all that yeah and that whole thing is
they stopped trying to be marvel yeah
yeah maybe
your camera that you're in the third
minute you're in the shadow room again
oh oh oh yeah you got your shadow around
because you you on our dream like
yo
king what what what camera you were
using today using the use of the new
joint use it we got to get this
120 frames per second i got to change it
but yeah maybe it's the frames it's too
high maybe that's what it is you need to
put it down
because zoom yeah you probably got it
too high that's what it is but anyway
that's all i got unless y'all got
anything else we'll be able to move on
to the last round yeah
get the nintendo
based on it
look real quick news the new joint you
know what it is um it looks like shout
out to them they don't want to leave
without talking no it's funny it's funny
oh it's funny it's funny all right so
two three news bits real quick headers
boom nintendo switch oled
banging out there japan looks like they
um
sold over 130 000 units in the first
three days of japan so that's moving
metroid drag triggered a franchise sales
boost oh okay let's stop that let me let
me put a pin in there right there all
right just because two people went out
and brought the old metroid it ain't no
sales
if okay
okay detroit all right
solve uh-huh if you have inventory on
your shelves oh right that's got
and then somebody buying all your dread
like oh oh oh and they go oh sweat this
is part of that yeah let me get two of
those
are you implying that they weren't
playing this
i love how he knows the stock he knows
the numbers
because of the nature of the switch
and how uh ubiquitous it is at this
point
it is the best-selling metroid all right
what does that mean for the future of
metro who knows who knows
i love it it's a good metroid game i i'm
enjoying it um but it is it is it is a
metroid metroid
for sure no surprise that wii u 3ds
switch whatever they see a little called
the king is four copies each um
moving on this the big one
nintendo switch online
expansion pass
release date and pricing reveal
so shout out to nintendo they announced
that they will make nintendo 64 and
genesis games available in this new
expansion service can i go first yes i
got you and then basically
like you know it's about to be lit where
attic asks to go first so pretty much um
they also said in this new tier of
expansion pass um because basically it's
double priced more than double the price
now he went from 25
um
it went from 25
to now i believe 50 uh dollars for the
um
twenty dollars yeah the original version
of the potential system along cost 20 a
year and 35 for my family nintendo
switch online expansion pack will be 50
a year and 80 for the family membership
and with with this thing you get the 64
games you get the genesis game and you
get an animal crossing expansion and the
word on the street is that if you don't
keep the subscription to the joint then
you don't keep the um animal experience
this is the hot joint at it you're
jumping where you at with the uh
nintendo um online expansion pack
this is the most
outrageous ridiculous thing i have ever
seen outrageous
together
[Laughter]
are they going to get away with it yes
yes
oh yeah dude look look it's it i'm
buying that instinct
baby you got by that win
it is it is what it is because
you see he might be myself
look look you know what's crazy if you
really sit there
and take it in
like if you think about it
they
this is the reason that they had the
mario for a certain time frame because
they wanted to
act like
the values in the service of this if you
didn't get mario when it was in the
stores
and what's funny
is
the mario that they sold to you for 30
to 60 depending if you get the because
since it came with multiple games
it's looking like that's the exact same
game in this service
show that to the legend of oz don't you
he's in here what a blessed how y'all
doing having a good time man it was
obviously everybody said it's outrageous
i said put a poll in saying who willing
to pay and who not willing to pay for
this expansion fact that
i'm paying i'm yeah
but we know you man we know you pay we
know you win so that's this look solve
where you at man how outlandish
assistance
is very outlandish
shout out to iron man you said no win
backs landed that cover system yes it
was you have get you have gears of war
because you had win back so don't know
listen
let's get out later
everybody with this holiday stupid
continue
so um yeah man it's one of those like
this is horrendous
[Laughter]
because the thing is you guys may
remember that i have been i was a
bamboozled into getting the switch oled
because
because my nephew
remember that i told him when the new
switch comes out yes
i i'm giving you mine right
so he remembered and he was like oh
there's a new switch i was like damn it
i guess i'm getting the oled and it's
fine i'm happy with that right but in
addition to that so i now i can finally
give them i'm gonna get rid of the base
switch i'm gonna get the lights and the
lights i'm gonna give to them so i'm
gonna get i'm gonna be in control of all
their switch stuff which meaning i'm
going to get the family plan
and allow my niece and nephew to rock
out with that so i'll be paying that 80
dollars
what a what a fun family plan
they can't play at the same time you
play
[Music]
regardless how it comes down to it
i'm explaining that regardless how it
comes down to i'm playing ocarina of
time i don't care
you're gonna play blurry ocarina time
look i i'm hoping that maybe it it
because because i do i just noticed that
they they are having some games running
at 60 frames on this right
it's still gonna be blurry at 60 fps i
don't care if it's blurry like see see i
i i i do care
but at the same time am i just not going
to play something that means that much
to me because
because they are making me play this
ridiculous price point
so another thing about it is
it the price is ridiculous because
they're points of comparison now right
if it was 50 on his own for remember
it's not 50 a month right 50 dollars for
a year or 80 yes
the thing is when you compare it to xbox
live gold
when you compare it to ps plus which are
both what one set price for whatever
it's superior services and superiors
with voice chats
party chat and messaging
and free games and free games
yes
there's a problem
are you implying there's a disparity in
quality there is a disparity in the
offerings offered
and the quality of service that is being
provided
overlooked
exactly this is this is the the red
lobster kitty menu the little buffet it
gives you with the baby shrimp the real
baby i know i got it
i know i got issues i ain't really act
like i don't like now they got me they
got me ain't nothing i can do them
why can't you break free what is it that
they it that they got you like what is
it
look it's just i love those older zelda
games and since they're
strategically not remade
for the new system which we all know
what's going on
now is the thing that's gonna happen is
next year we're gonna get a zelda
collector's edition but it's only sold
for two months
this is ridiculous the fact
the fact that they're not giving you at
least a 3ds remake like like
i i mean i would rather pay 60 dollars
for the remake like i'm gonna be real
with you i'm gonna be broke all of this
i'm about all it is what they doing to
y'all
the next experience should pass
the dreamcast pack
they do they do the neogeo oh i got i
got that already oh
i know i know where to do it for cobb i
already know you know what it is i don't
know
but i ain't happening but
it's wrestling yeah they do them
wrestling games i mean i'm i'm selling
my soul like
i deserve everything that's gonna happen
to you now yeah
you
let's get some more
[Music]
business practices from your favorite
company so hey that's why they could
sell you a week console with an old
screen that's why they didn't
said thou shall not purchase
what's up but you were literally about
to pledge your fealty to them and just
something happened to happen had to stop
god you're like god gonna stop at it god
gonna say he gonna put his credit card
and they're gonna really think about the
situation
and i already got these games somewhere
in this house like you won't everybody
is buying this stuff you got these games
and you go in there you say you know
what nintendo put in a nice little
package all together
i'm gonna go get it and they told you
the free stuff that they gave with it
that you purchased
if you leave
[Laughter]
when that comes out you could be sitting
with your hating ass on top of your
little eiffel tower
imma be sitting in front of my switch
playing ocarina of time
small from here y'all gonna love the
pole that's all good
you know what he is so lit at
he just keeps saying this so because
he's trying his his mind is trying to
talk about it i'm with you i'm there
with you at it
you know what you hear him saying like
his mind is saying addict stop doing
that and when he yells i don't care he
ain't saying it to me
i don't care
you know it's interesting i'll just wrap
up quick oh the thing about it from what
i from the reasoning we hear
according to um there's an inside
nintendo insider that yeah here's the
reason what miles wrote what's this
is out of pocket i love miles he's so
loose right now he buying all of that he
don't care what y'all talking about he
buying it all respect bob i feel that
but they said why did why is nintendo
getting away with charging these absurd
prices and shout out to mike monad he's
got a he got a hilarious he said this is
absurd this is ridiculous right but what
they're saying is that um according this
leaker emily rogers she's been she's
been right a lot before shout out to
nintendo like they said the main culprit
for the is supposed to be licensing cost
apparently sega wasn't a big fan of the
wii's virtual console back in the day
due to the low sales and other issues so
nintendo had to fork out a big bit of
cash for mega drive genesis library they
said licensing courts are the main
culprit behind this prac of this past
and they said that's why sega didn't
support wii u
vc so they had to give sega back then
the rumor is microsoft they had to give
a bag as far as um the banjo kazooie
stuff and third party titles it's
probably a way smaller bags yeah smaller
bags probably you know i'm saying capcom
so the rumor is that the reason why it's
so crazy is now the question is though
if they
continue to add more of these consoles
and it doesn't like
is the price gonna go up more
well they're not eating nothing like
literally they just told you sega
charging me more so i'm charging you
double and then shout out to nelson
rivera in the chase and then wiring crew
genesis that's my point too like if
genesis cost that much drop it
drop it or or bringing it at the back
end when after you have all your own
consoles in there yeah and then you you
roll it in the dough the extra dough
whatever the cash back because you were
going to bring the price up anyway
but but then you could have brought the
price up more gradually rather than wow
so what what if it's a thing that they
have plans let's say that they're going
to add more stuff and they already
they're making us pay the upfront
ridiculous price now maybe as they add
we'll talk about nintendo
oh they're gonna come around they're
gonna fix that's right they're not fake
what you got and that's it and if they
put anything extra in there you are
gonna pay
look man
i'm able to stay strong right now
because they they got my heart here so i
could resist right now guess what king
yo here you go
you know they they really are the worst
they're the worst they are the worst
they like
they're horrible this is horrible this
is horrible
yeah it's shout out to jeff grubby he's
like i guess nintendo really want that
they want some money right now but it is
what it is but let's get this poll let's
get up out of here um
diego like it do i have people with the
recent pricing announcement of nintendo
switch online do you think the pricing
is fair
based on
the content received the choices are yes
the market dictates the value and switch
owners are willing to pay for a premium
animal crossing expansion and genesis in
the nintendo 64 game stop pocket
watching king
b
no the
online expansion is more than double the
price of standard nintendo online still
no messaging still no party chat no core
online services features to match a
competition grandpa nintendo still out
here finessing y'all
see i don't care all this taking a stand
against nintendo sound nice until they
put them dreamcast saturn and gamecube
games on nintendo
shout out to everybody hit that like
button it will be going up on
lordsofgaming.net
again everybody much salute we had the
legendary seth chazelle in the building
absolute pleasure got the class give us
the class one more time what time put
your head together
[Applause]
it was absolutely amazing salute to the
support everybody that pulled up saw if
you want to get some super chats and
then we all roll up out of here and then
let me know how that poll results is for
that um who getting financed by nintendo
who will it get for this
i want names to tell you we knew what it
was going to do
90 percent
of money or not pay the money no no they
said no they're not
yeah i don't know oh wow
well listen i would call base
yeah they're not with that yet yeah yeah
no doubt no doubt all right guys
we got out
dc fandom was lit static live action
film in the works too that small part
was awash in all the news that hit hard
yesterday like i said even the small
stuff is getting getting shine um
then we have okay i've did this one
twice native two dollars which shout out
to the ip family this chat is fire
let's put the crust in the chat for andy
crawley absolutely welcome to the realm
it says remember six months but i guess
there was a change in the and the uh the
membership so
shout out to andy crawley then we got a
five dollar super chat from andy crawley
hi lord it's been a while keep it up for
us
much love
now we got brett bingham five dollar
super chat excited to see fable by
playground i hope they take a page from
bethesda and give us some variety of
weapon design styles and customization
no doubt
yeah then we got brett bingham once
again 10 super chat just talked about
two unannounced projects project xiaolin
and belf yes
yes
my bold predictions are an mk game or
possibly killer instinct 2 made by
netherrealm and a silent hill game
i like the name project shaolin that
sounds funny i like that
then we got clutch man five dollar super
chat xbox marketing should hire cabbie
to show how easy it is to use quick
resume and game pass quick resume and
other
svs services services
then we have urban ninja five dollar
super chat you can buy dev mode on your
series s on your series for twenty
dollars and add emulators i hate those
games
i'm paying 80
doubt damn doubt no doubt
there we have iron mike with the two
dollars in the chat it's the chi chi's
peaches of buffets is it chi chi's or
cici's how do you say it
then we have
40 rupees super chat nintendo giving us
more reasons for emulations see this is
the thing about
emulating the new nintendo stuff
it's a little harder so when you think
about
who the the who the nintendo customer is
more often than not it's not gonna
really be an issue like you have your
people yes you know people older they
know the way around the computer you
could emulate this stuff
but
kid ain't emulating that like they're
not they're not getting the new stuff
isn't getting pirated like that
all right and we got two more super
chats we got doovey doing five dollars
of a jack why so many people saying
they'll try it for a month and then
there's a and there's a monthly option
like this a monthly option
nintendo the modern day gangsters of the
video game yes
listen and that's the fear
like king said the price keeps going up
and they just start charging you a
monthly fee
and they and they would do something
like charge you thirty dollars a month
no games out here any plan
brett big on five dollar super chat i
mean if the crystal d is working with
the initiative on perfect diet it's not
a stretch that netherrealm would work on
killer instinct too i told y'all about
the crystal d
super chats we went through this
[Laughter]
oh i don't like that
it's okay guys i approve the christmas
yeah they know what they doing that's
what it is they're being silly so y'all
caught up yeah we're cutting up the
attic we're going to find people find
you good to have you back sir
you can you can find me on twitter lord
addict iop i will be streaming demon
souls tomorrow uh so definitely be
looking out for that is that the
playstation 3 version
[Laughter]
i will be streaming that so definitely
come through on that um
we will be rescheduling the chivalry
stream yeah and um we're going to be
starting the
the little early stuff that we're going
to do probably the next two weeks we're
going to have the
um the
roundabout table podcast
uh so keep looking on the uh keep
looking out for that um i guess people
are
messaging me on twitter i guess they you
guys said something about me playing old
games on patreon well what did you say
that yeah yeah yeah you weren't paid you
weren't paying attention to that
get you in the mix
well i definitely didn't hear that well
i don't know we'll have to talk about
that yeah yes
so uh definitely you know appreciate it
for coming through appreciate uh seth
for coming through who's a great guest
uh you know we got some more stuff
planned for you guys man we
we we we're definitely you know we we
have stuff for this year but i want to
point out like we we are
we are already in our our midst to what
we're doing next year so we
we're already in that we're already
cooking up with the guests man uh you
know we calling our road to e3 man we're
we're
getting into that uh you know everything
we do is because of this chat because
whatever you guys do in this chat uh you
guys are solely responsible
for giving king a sound deck yes so you
know
that there's that
[Laughter]
but yeah i definitely appreciate every
music though that over here i can't do
it because i i don't want us to get
monetized because oh just in case you
don't know if they bought
that
say something brother say something also
i want to shout out um for merch my
favorite name
black conflict x yeah he just got that
classic full over hoodie piece you know
what i'm saying bless his brother i like
that you know what i said and i think i
think we're in the future we might do a
giveaway on on the merchandise i know a
lot of you guys like getting that so we
might do some kind of uh
like raffle or something with the with
the merchandise shout out to phones
really you guys are yeah we solved you
got phones up there
yes sir
[Music]
i'll talk to the people where can they
find you yeah but first of all big shout
out to seth man seth uh that dude uh i'm
really excited about i'm in awe
i'm kind of yeah he that that's a very
smart dude he's been he's seen a lot of
things done a lot of things and the fact
that he's at the forefront of how
microsoft interfaces with us yeah is is
is kind of special and and and we should
be excited about
just not worrying about microsoft trying
to be not not telling us what's going on
i think it's a very special thing so
shout out to him yeah and like like cox
said i will be on games talk live at 5
00 p.m eastern time with jay fonzarelli
the whole yeah i am actually i'm
terrified of these five questions you
know the five questions you gonna get
your games talk live yeah
man
make sure y'all support funds man he
right after us he's right after us go to
the home funds really games talk live
well no actually we're he pushed back
today oh he got a little yeah yeah yeah
5 p.m eastern time
you know what i'm saying okay megan just
showing love salute thank you brother
much love that's my fight
[Applause]
and of course the king in rare form
today where can you find people finding
what you got going on sir okay first
first of you guys um we want to let you
know that the new merch is coming yes
all right so the new merch is going to
be uh up in store for all the 10k
subscribers all you guys that are here
thank you so much we do appreciate
everything that you do we we first of
all i love the chat you guys keep it
clean and keep it right yeah i mean uh
it's one of the best chats ever actually
because of you people uh
microphone
uh camera even though my camera's
freezing i'm in the shadow room i got it
i wanted to put it in you put your
afraid you yeah you back survive
you put your little man you took a
little man to the left you know what i'm
worried about though i'm worried that
the once we're all on all these cameras
gonna be so hot that the bandwidth won't
first i want to give a shout out to my
boy a true gamer 79. uh
congratulations to microsoft because he
we in him dm yeah you know mostly all
the time and he dm me that um microsoft
xbox uk uh the series x took home the
best console
in that award
so and what he said was he said uh
little man should have won two
he said uh my brother just brought one
and he loves the little man's power sure
right so you know little man's out here
playing above his waist above his face
i told him i talked about it on the show
and he had said something like you know
uh if i said you know i'm nobody but
you're somebody brother you are somebody
to me because i i correspond with you
all the time and i do appreciate that
you there so don't ever think low of
yourself i am not no high person i am
just a regular person absolutely that
talks with you all the time so i respect
the dm's me and you talk all the time
and i told you i was going to talk about
it on the show absolutely um
seth
yes
i'm out
that interview was insane yeah yeah he
gave us he gave us a lie
yeah he's
like he's been at every junction point
of every technological advancement yeah
yes we have seen and he can and his
memory take away your tvs from your kids
right now
if you didn't see something right now
what you served his mother said no tv's
in the house get them tvs out of this
now
but nah man um great great show today oh
i got to give applause to myself
[Applause]
this is why he can't have things these
are the reasons
yo you know why i'm able to do it
because my joint is wired y'all want to
be all freestyling
y'all don't know that that's jerry has
functions because y'all are wireless
shout out to me for breathing you know
you know what's funny chat i don't know
the chat doesn't know this we all have
one we all have the power to do this
they cannot do it because they are they
they've got very expensive headsets
i got the cheapy choppy so i found out
that we we're gonna take care of this
because we all get this we all need this
power yeah he got too much this power's
too much once he stopped putting in
sands and stuff it's gonna be over
it's over listen guys thank you all so
much we do appreciate everything that
you're doing um i'm talking with the
lords
we want to give away a console when we
hit 15k yes um and we're gonna put it
out there to you guys what consoles
should that be yeah should that be the
switch oled
should that be the little man should
that be series x should that be a
playstation five yeah don't worry you
ain't gotta fight club and fight it out
but we're trying to figure out the
parameters for that for subscribers
members of the realm and our patreon
subscribers yeah we're doing more stuff
with your patreon with us patreon people
um lords of gaming.net i cannot say it
enough
i was at the barber shop this week and i
gave my business card to a patreon that
was there
and
a patron
a patreon that was there and he went to
the website and he just looked at me and
said brother i want to shake your hand
oh wow
because
this
is crazy professional this is very nice
absolutely he said i'm gonna watch on
sunday so
please guys if you haven't got a chance
to go check it out i don't talk out my
rear when i'm talking about i feel that
our site is better than you know
everybody else because i go there for my
information and i like the writers i and
we you know we have different things
that's going on so please check it out i
know i'm talking too much sorry no no no
no you're good you're good you're good
salute man yeah
shout out to gonna wait that bluetooth
king's on fire
no doubt no doubt yeah akw no doubt hit
up solve for that yeah man look
tremendous so
super proud man i mean [ __ ]
[Applause]
he's just so ridiculous i love it
it's so ridiculous
yeah man look it was it was a absolute
you know honor to have him
and to hear you know your peers say
hey we respect our in-laws podcast hey
yes you know
we we you you guys have a reputation
that means a lot you know we we're not
the biggest you know but at the same
time i'm super proud of the community we
built i'm super proud of the respect you
know and at the end of the day that that
to me means more than any of that number
stuff because
to me that's what it's about you know
just talking games having fun his story
was tremendous look microsoft made a
good acquisition they made a great
acquisition with this guy
he's been doing it and put it down a
long time and from the journalism side
and from the fact that he's been able to
touch
all the major players in the game and
that that bodes well that bodes well for
them so good choice by let them look
forward to seeing what they do in the
future again the realm was lit salute to
all y'all for pulling up tremendous um
support the chat is always like addict
said we got crazy big things going on
like king said we got more merch coming
more stuff everything that we we get we
give it back to y'all put it back in the
podcast so expect big things man but
that's all i got unless anybody else got
any other announcements one more stupid
chat yes sir let's do it we got a
splendiferous
two dollars if we chat king with great
power comes great dot dot dot yeah they
call him alternating
power
[Music]
alter ego addicts said we should put the
link to the website in the youtube
actually should be in the youtube
description yeah if you look
now
check real quick before i close out i
want to make sure he's seeing that if we
the live show right now the youtube
description should be at the top should
launchinggaming.net or to ego but if not
we will correct it just let me know if
it's in the attic on the live show
aren't we in the description i thought
it was part of our default settings but
um yeah man shout out to one away shot
everybody shot the pong up in there
miles oh okay asante salute brother
salute to the lord for another monument
to so much love to you brother is it in
there
no there's nothing in there oh okay so
my live show it's a live show my fault
we will fix that i'll make sure on the
live shows it's there ksnt i did try i
downloaded you you lost echo game but i
got caught up i was telling them earlier
about the um
the other virtual joint traveling while
black that jordan just hit me in the
heart it was it was crazy but look
that's all i got
we are out of here everybody until next
week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you